Alo.
Ờ
xin chào tất cả các bạn.
máy nãy giờ bị nóng quá nên phải mở quạt
to hết cỡ hết công suất.
rồi đúng không ạ? Thế là tôi còn đáng lẽ
là tôi bảo là định lên
quá thì không nói. Ờ
tôi còn định kiểu soạn một bài văn này
dùng AI để sửa lại kết hợp việc là ờ xem
lại là lần cuối mình livestream là lúc
nào. Uầy 11 tháng trước. Ui gần 1 năm
rồi. Tôi cứ nghĩ mới chỉ có
thôi mới nghĩ là cũng chỉ mới có tầm à
hứa từ đầu năm nay. Thì mình thất hứa từ
tận đầu năm đến giờ. Thế mà đã gần 1 năm
rồi. Nhanh thật đấy. Ừ. Đầu tiên thì
à xin chào mấy ông. Có thể là
tôi thực ra tôi để ý kỹ là mấy ông
thường hay ờ mấy ông thường hay xem lại
hoặc là xem không đúng không đúng giờ
livestream bởi vì thấy lượt đã xem khá
là
khá là nhiều cho rồi lúc livestream thì
chỉ có chỉ có tầm mười mấy bạn là căng
đấy. Uầy lên tận 14. Chắc là hôm nay
cũng
là lúc mà các bạn nghỉ hè à. À không,
nhóm nhóm người xem của tôi chắc không
phải là mấy bạn gì à khối nghỉ hè đâu.
như là cái
phải ngồi căn. Tôi chưa căn được mấy cái
đấy không ạ? Nãy giờ tôi bị trễ hẹn bởi
vì tôi cứ mở cái camera lên. Hôm nay
ngồi khoe cam
mới. Mic thì vẫn là mic từ thời đấy
nhưng cam mới nếu mà mấy ông để ý kỹ thì
nó sẽ rõ nét hơn. Đấy. Ờ
thế nên là tôi kiểu
ngồi chỉnh cam kiểu gì mà cam
cài mở phần mềm nó lên ấy chắc là do cả
máy tôi có thể yếu nữa. Máy là máy part
à.
Được thầ 30 phút á. Thoải mái tôi thực
ấy nói khi nào mấy ông kiểu chám chẳng
biết nói gì nữa rồi mà. Đấy thì máy tôi
máy P thì rõ ràng nó mạnh về cái mỏng
nhẹ đúng không ạ? Nên là
cấu hình nó có vẻ không tốt cho lắm. Mở
mỗi cái cam kết hợp phần mềm của cam.
Chắc là phần mềm cam nó cũng có thể chục
chặc gì đấy. Vì tôi đang dùng Window.
Ờ để mà nói thì gần đây có dùng song
song à Windows với MacBook ở trên công
ty cho dù là cũng có ý định là sẽ chuyển
qua Linus rồi đấy. Thì
nói chung là vẫn dùng Windows thì có vẻ
là quay lại win cảm thấy chênh lệch hẳn
ý. kiểu đang dùng máy M công nhận là độ
mượt để mà nói nhá thì nó là
ừ chắc là tôi quen việc nhanh rồi, thao
tác mọi thứ nhanh rồi. Thế nên là máy M
ở trên công ty tôi cũng cảm thấy nó vẫn
đang
kiểu chưa đủ nhanh bằng cái tốc độ của
mình kiểu thao tác các thứ nó vẫn sẽ có
độ chậm, độ trễ, độ delay hay gì đó đúng
không ạ? Đấy nhưng mà quay lại máy win
ui kiểu đấy nãy giờ mấy ông thấy tôi mất
tôi vào tôi ngồi chuẩn bị từ 7:45 đấy
đến vừa mới livestream xong chứ kiểu cứ
ngồi cài cái các thứ thứ
à
giọng anh nghe hay phết chắc là nhờ cái
mic ấy mic này là mic a thời đấy là mua
cũng là giống mấy anh Độ à anh Độ đ cả
mấy anh livestream khác đây cái mic đây
mấy ông nhìn thấy không
đy
Cấn gì Cấn Lân Giang hay gì đó tôi nhớ
có một bạn hot girl tên cái tên đấy hi
vọng hi vọng không ai nghe thấy điều này
ông. Mấy ông có thể ờ kiểu đặt câu hỏi
các thứ nhá. Lôi lắm rồi không trả lời
câu hỏi mấy ông luôn. Hồi trước tâm sự
cũng xóa gần hết rồi.
À đấy form câu hỏi ui
lâu lắm rồi.
không để ý câu hỏi nhiều thế.
Đây tôi sẽ ngồi trả lời. Tôi sẽ cố ngồi
trả lời hết cái này rồi tí còn xóa bớt
đi. 3 năm trước xem video của anh đã ra
được trường giờ thất nghiệp. Thất nghiệp
á? Ờ đúng là thời buổi này cũng khó
khăn. Tôi cũng hồi trước tôi cũng cố hỗ
trợ mấy ông làm cái trang web kiểu môi
giới việc làm để mà kiểu môi giới cho
chính mấy ông cũng như là hỗ trợ cho các
bạn HR. Nhưng mà thời cuối giờ khó khăn
thì đúng là
khó hứa hẹn được điều gì.
Nên chính tôi gần đây là tôi cũng à đấy
thì tôi muốn nói là kiểu lâu rồi không
tâm sự đúng không ạ? Thì trong một năm
qua tôi đã như thế nào? Thì trong năm
qua tôi lại phấn đấu kiểu cho dù là gần
đây anh leader của tôi anh có bảo là
trong hai năm qua thì anh tiến bộ rất là
nhanh. còn các em có vẻ là chậm hơn so
với anh nhưng mà tôi cảm thấy là
ờ năm qua tôi vẫn là một năm tiến bộ rất
rất nhiều ờ và
kiểu
để mà nói như này nh tiến bộ ở đây không
phải tiến bộ trong mỗi lập trình nhá
tiến bộ chung về mặt tư duy về cứ cho là
nhân sinh quan nó cũng sẽ có sự tôi cảm
thấy là nó là thay đổi nhưng mà theo mặt
tích cực khá là nhiều. Đấy,
bạn. Mấy bạn thì thự ra thường những
người mà bây giờ mà theo bây giờ ngồi
đây xem thì chắc là những bạn từ thời
đầu chứ thật ra lâu lắm rồi tôi không
livestream này, tôi cũng không quảng báo
gì kênh của mình, không chạy quảng cáo
không gì cả. thì các bạn biết đến tôi
hoặc là vào xem thì chắc là toàn những
người cũ thôi.
Xin chào các bạn.
Các bạn có câu hỏi gì thì tôi ghim ở kia
các bạn cứ hỏi nhá. Tôi sẽ trả lời. Thực
ra là mấy cái câu này tôi
không đợi tôi một tí. Tôi hình như là
tôi có tôi có mục để mà ngồi xem cái a
Đợi tôi tí đi ạ. Để tôi có mục để tôi
xem a
nằm ở file Excel nào để tôi xem là tôi
phải hiển thị mốc thời gian ở đây. Tôi
chẳng nhớ mấy câu hỏi này đã từ bao lâu
rồi ý.
là ông bạn của tôi này.
ông nếu mà mấy ông có thấy thật ra tôi
công khai nhưng công khai hơi
hơi kiểu nhở nghĩa là tôi có công khai
trên nền tảng mạng xã hội nhưng tôi sẽ
không rầm rộ tôi sẽ không kiểu
ví dụ là để chế độ hẹn hò nhưng mà không
để
gọi là như nào
có cái nút là chia sẻ lên trang trang
chủ ý thì tôi không ấn nút đấy.
Thực ra tôi có ấn chính ra còn chơi có
trò cũng chích chích một tí. Đó là tôi
có ấn nhưng mà hồi đấy là hôm đấy mùng 4
mùng 1 hôm đấy ngày cắn tháng tư mà tôi
chỉ để chế độ hẹn đang hẹn hò thôi nhưng
mà không tát cụ thể một ai vào cả không
đánh giấu một ai vào nên là thành ra là
mọi người cứ tưởng là hôm đấy là kiểu
trêu trêu đấy xong mấy ngày sau rồi tôi
mới tác hẳn người đấy vào. Nhưng mà
đương nhiên là lúc đấy nó sẽ không thông
báo gì nữa nên là chỉ hiển nhiên là
hiển nhiên là mình đã công khai nhưng mà
thực tế là không có cái
khả năng nào cả.
Độc thân đi cho năng suất. À tôi hôm
trước tôi có nói chuyện đấy với
anh sếp anh leader của tôi. Tôi vừa nói
thì anh a
nếu mà không lạm dụng tiếng Anh mình sẽ
dùng từ gì nhỉ? Anh trưởng nhóm à? Ờ anh
trưởng nhóm thì anh đấy bảo là tôi và
một vài bạn nữa đang chậm hơn so anh đấy
đúng không? Cái lúc đấy tôi mới phân
tích bắc tách ra là thực tế là
có thể là do là anh đấy đã có vợ con nên
là tính ra là anh đấy sẽ không kiểu cái
độ phân bổ thời gian của anh đấy
nó sẽ chỉ một là đi làm hai là về với về
nhà chăm lo gia đình nó sẽ ít nhất là
cắt đi cái khoản kiểu ra ngoài đi tìm
hiểu hay ra ngoài đi hẹn hò hay kiểu thế
bởi vì kiểu cứ cho là an cư lạt nghiệp
đi. An cư ở đây nó sẽ không chỉ dừng ở
mỗi chỗ là là
ăn cư ở đây là là đã ổn định về mặt gia
đình ấy thì ông sẽ chỉ tập trung vào
những cái sự nghiệp hay các thứ khác
thôi. Đương nhiên là ông vẫn phải có
thời gian dành cho gia đình nhưng mà
đương nhiên là cái độ phân bổ nó khác và
đương nhiên là hết thời kỳ ăn chơi các
thứ vui vẻ với anh em rồi đấy. Mà anh
đấy cũng cắt mấy cái đấy cơ. Anh đấy
kiểu cũng là người cũng không thích đi
chơi, không thích ra ngoài lắm. Nói
chung là sởi thích của anh đấy sẽ là chủ
yếu xoay quanh một vừa ngồi lập trình
ngồi nói chung là làm một cái phần mềm
gì đó có thể kiếm được ra tiền hay là
kiểu ở ở nhà với vợ con thậm chí là nhậu
với nhậu với vợ thôi. Đấy kiểu thế cuối
tuần thì dắt vợ đi à dắt vợ con đi công
viên đấy. kiểu thế thì rõ ràng là cái
thời gian anh ấy dành cho công nghệ thì
rất rất nhiều nên thành ra là trình của
anh đấy cũng sẽ lên rất nhiều đấy. So
với bọn tôi, bọn tôi vẫn có thời gian
này kiểu thời gian đi hẹn hò tìm hiểu
hay là
khám phá thêm về bản thân như kiểu là
đôi khi là giải trí vân vân nhiều cái
nữa. Hôm nấy tôi cũng nói anh đấy, anh
ấy hơi nhạt. Kiểu anh ấy ít sở thích
khác ngoài làm việc nên thành ra là kiểu
nó sẽ khó mà so sánh ấy. Đấy,
chúng ta không so sánh kiểu đấy được.
Đợi tôi một tí nhá. Tôi ngồi tìm cái a
tôi mở được cái link à mở được cái phần
này lên chứ bây giờ nhìn trông kiểu này.
Anh sinh năm bao nhiêu mà trông trẻ thế
ạ? Ờ xin chào bạn. Nếu bạn mới biết đến
kênh của mình, mình sinh năm 97
à 1997 đấy. Cho dù là mình sinh đầu năm
nên có thể tính là 96 cũng được nhưng mà
gọi như là ờ mình trông trẻ chắc là hôm
qua mới cạo dâu bình thường là trông sẽ
hơi ông cụ non một tí.
T rách
rách cũng mới được. Kiểu kìa mới được
đòi lại một tí công lý các thứ rồi. Chắc
là bây giờ so sánh thì vẫn oai.
bây giờ làm nào để public nhỉ? Ui lâu
lắm mà không động vào luôn.
Ấn đi. Ok.
này đúng không? Uầy, 2024 ạ.
Ôi, vài câu hỏi từ 2024.
Ờ lỗi tôi có cái từ 2023 này à
nên tôi tắt đi. Như có vẻ là
nhỉ? Rõ ràng là chuẩn là phải cái gọi là
mới nhất đây. Bởi vì cái ông đấy đang
ngồi xem chứ đúng không? Chắc chắn là
cái ông này đang ngồi xem này. Nhưng mà
có những cái từ 2023
tôi vẫn đang nếu mà làm chính thức kiểu
gọi là full time. Full time từ nào khác
không? Không phải tiếng Anh tiếng Việt
nhỉ? Làm à làm giờ hành chính nói chung
là chính thức thì sẽ là à mình
tôi vẫn đi lập trình, vẫn làm ở công ty
cũ.
Tôi đã gần như là thành nhân viên thâm
niên gần như lâu nhất, gần như lâu nhất
ở công ty hiện tại. Đấy, bởi vì công ty
hiện tại tôi làm hơn 4 năm rồi. Từ nghĩa
là trước cả cái thời livestream này đúng
không ạ? Ờ
còn thỉnh thoảng là vẫn có nhận không
hẳn là nhận dạy thêm mà là có người thân
giới thiệu và cũng gọi là cũng thấy là
không ảnh hưởng gì đến công việc nên
thành ra là tôi vẫn nhận. Hiện tại thì
cũng vừa mới kết thúc cái khóa đấy xong.
Tức là hồi trước tôi vẫn nhớ nhá. Hồi
trước là có dạy thêm bên a
cao đoàn nghề không phải cao đoàn nghề
Bách Khoa đâu, nó là
Hute à Hute Hute Bách Khoa gần sau đó ơ
cũng đúng 1 năm trước đấy. Sau đó thì à
gian lại nhận dậy bên tuyển sinh 247.
Tuyển sinh 247 thì là
kiểu tại sao lại dạy bên tuyển sinh 247?
Bởi vì là bây giờ năm vừa rồi các bạn
thấy là các bạn chắc cũng biết rồi. Năm
vừa rồi là mới thay đổi là tin học có
thể tính là một môn thi tốt nghiệp, có
thể ngoài thi tốt nghiệp là có thể tuyển
chọn thi vào các trường và người môn tin
học nữa. Và chương trình học của tin học
năm lớp 12 bây giờ sẽ khá khá là có
nhiều cái của năm nhất đại học đẩy xuống
nên thành ra là tôi mới dạy được chứ chư
từ trước nay tôi chưa dạy cấp bao giờ
cả. Từ trước nay tôi mới chỉ kiểu dạy
kiểu chuyên để dạy nghề hơn ấy. Đấy công
nhận là hồi đấy ngồi soạn giáo án đương
nhiên cảm ơn cảm ơn rất nhiều AI cảm ơn
rất nhiều Chat TVT vân vân. Đấy, tôi mở
cái tab riêng cho TV kia bởi vì một ngày
tôi hỏi nó rất nhiều và tôi tận dụng nó
rất rất không thể nói trệt để vì mình
không phải kỹ sư AI hay cái gì đó, không
phải thần thánh về à không phải gọi là
chuyên gia về prom nhưng mà thực sự thì
mình đã tận dụng được nó khá là nhiều
đấy.
Thì để nó ngồi soạn. Bây giờ ông cứ hình
dung nhá. Tôi hồi đấy tôi làm tôi dạy
hai khóa. Một khóa là khóa để luyện thi
được trên lớp. Ok. Khóa đấy vẫn là dạy
kiến thức trên lớp. Ok. Vẫn soạn bài tập
các thứ. Thực ra vẫn dùng AI nhưng mà
vẫn có thể tự soạn được. Ok. Giống như
hồi trước tôi làm bài bài mấy cái bài
trắc nghiệm soạn cho mấy ông ấy. Tiếp là
tôi phải làm thêm một khóa nữa. Luyện
thi. Nghĩa là làm đề thi thử cho cái kỳ
thi tốt nghiệp vừa rồi. 15 đề mỗi đề là
40 câu. 40 hay là nhiều hơn ấy. Ờ hình
như 40 thì phải. Nói chung cứ tầm đấy.
40 thực ra nhiều hơn đấy đúng không nhỉ?
Đúng rồi, nhiều hơn một tí. Như nói
chung cứ tầm cứ cho 40 câu nhá. 40 câu
15 đề nhân lên là bao nhiêu ạ? Nó là 600
câu hỏi trắc nghiệm. Đấy, làm sao mà một
người bình thường có thể nghĩ ra được
những câu đấy mà không trùng nhau ạ?
Đấy, thì rõ ràng là nhờ ai rất nhiều.
Tôi ngồi đấy là tôi ngồi soạn hết, tôi
ngồi đọc sách, tôi ngồi gõ lại những
kiến thức tổng hợp từ sách vân vân vân.
Tôi chọn lọc các thứ thứ để xong rồi
nhập liệu vào AI để mà AI kiểu nó sẽ từ
cái đống kiến thức đấy nó gợi ý ra những
câu hỏi. Đương nhiên là tôi vẫn phải
duyệt chỉnh sửa lại chứ không thì cái
nghề nghề tôi chuyển hình nghề soạn giáo
án bằng ai rồi nên thực sự là
hỗ trợ được rất rất nhiều. nó
nhẹ đi nói chung là khiến cho ít nhất là
bản thân mình ấy sẽ luôn cảm thấy có
người đồng hành và cảm thấy bớt ngại hơn
chắc chắn. Bây giờ nếu giả sử ví dụ hôm
nay một cái điển hình thôi luôn. Hôm nay
là một trong những cái công việc hàng
ngày thôi nhưng mà tôi chỉ nói ví dụ
thôi. Ví dụ hôm nay tôi là một trong
nói dung từ lần đầu cũng đúng bởi vì mọi
khi là tôi sẽ đẩy bình thường tôi đẩy
code lên web
ờ lên hosting của chính mình thuê ấ thì
hồi trước là bằng những cái tool đấy.
Nhưng mà hôm nay lần đầu
ghi bằng command SSH xong rồi nhập mọi
thứ lệnh lên ý. Báo lỗi cái gì tôi hỏi
AI nó sẽ gợi ý đến đấy. Thì cảm thấy là
hồi trước mà mình ngồi mò đọc tài liệu
để mà làm mấy cái vụ này mình cảm thấy
ngại kinh khủng. Đấy, còn bây giờ có hỗ
trợ cho thấy kiểu có vấn đề thì mình cứ
gửi cho nó xong rồi bảo nó giải thích
từng cái một cho mình để mình cũng tự
mình cũng suy ra được nhiều cái thôi
nhưng mà công nhận là cũng đỡ hơn nhiều.
đến đi dạy được tin học không anh? Ơ thì
tôi cũng học Cao Đẳng mà tôi chừa đại
học mà.
Ờ nhưng mà
đương nhiên về sau tôi vẫn cố học liên
thông để lấy cái bằng đại học nhá. Nhưng
mà tôi hướng đến là đấy đúng là để về
sau có bằng đại học hay là thậm chí là
về sau nữa là phần đầu có thạc sĩ gì đó
để mà dạy được đại học. Nhưng mà thực tế
là là
nếu có đầu tiên là nếu có kiến thức.
Kiến thức ở đây là cả lý thuyết và thực
hành. Phải có thực hành nhá. Rất nhiều
thầy bây giờ tôi nói thẳng luôn là kiến
thức thực hành không còn thực tế nữa nên
thành ra đi dạy nó hơi phải dùng từ là
hơi hợi thì thiếu thực tế thôi gọi là
không không sát với thực tế khiến cho
dạy đấy cứ cho là dạy được mỗi cái lý
thuyết cơ bản đôi khi là nó phải dùng từ
lý thuyết suông thì rõ ràng còn đúng nữa
đâu. Đấy thời đại công nghệ là nó thay
đổi liên tục rồi đúng không ạ? Đấy,
đương nhiên là dạy cho học sinh tư duy
là tốt nhưng mà thực sự là ra trường mà
không áp dụng được thì không ổn. Đấy,
thực ra là đấy là một trong những cái lý
do mà tôi cảm thấy cho dù bộ không nói
nhưng tôi nghĩ là nó đúng. Tức là đẩy
hết kiến thức của năm nhất xuống cấp 3.
Cấp 3 nhá. Không phải mỗi lớp 12 đâu.
Nghĩa là ngay từ lớp 10 bây giờ đã chọn
có thể thi môn tin học hay không rồi. Là
lớp 10 bây giờ không còn học mỗi cái môn
mà hồi trước bọn tôi từng học nữa. Chỉ
mỗi B scan không không học access nữa.
Access hơi vô dụng thời đấy. Bây giờ học
hẳn những cái phần mềm giống như là
Headies. Cái tôi từng dùng các bạn heyql
này. Đấy xong rồi học Python này. Đấy
đây C cộng c+ cũng có thể một vài trường
vẫn dạy nhưng bây giờ chủ yếu là Python.
Đấy xong rồi dạy về nhập môn mạng nhập
dạy cả một tí về nhập môn về AI các thứ
nữa để cho học sinh có thể hình dung
được à học công nghệ đông tin nó là như
thế nào chưa tránh cái việc là vào đại
học mới biết. vào đại học mới biết thì
nhiều bạn bị sốc rất nhiều nên là khó
theo và các trường không có đủ thời gian
để mà vừa dậy vừa dỗ các bạn trong vòng
4 năm đấy mà các bạn còn phải đi thực
tập sớm nữa. Thường là các bạn học chán
chết ở trên trường xong các bạn ra
trường mới bắt đầu đi thực tập là hơi
muộn. Phả dùng từ hơi muộn. Đấy, còn bây
giờ khi mà các bạn học dần, hiểu dần gọi
là cứ cho là
cứ cho là làm quen dần ngay từ hồi cấp
ba ấy mà các bạn xác định theo được ấy
thì khi lên đại học mình khẳng định là
nhàn hơn rất nhiều. Và nếu mà kiến thức
trên đại học còn thay đổi theo kiểu là
để thì kiến thức cấp ba thì học mấy cái
môn đại cương và cơ bản đúng không? Thì
lên đại học sẽ phải thay đổi chứ đúng
không ạ? Thế ra mình chưa biết chưa biết
được sách của đại học hay kiến thức đại
học đã thay đổi chưa. Lâu lắm mình không
đi dạy nhưng mà nếu mà có thay đổi thì
nó sẽ rất tốt. Bởi vì là nếu thế thì năm
nhất à năm cuối của đại học là hoàn toàn
có thể đi thực tập được rồi vì đã có
nhiều thời gian học hơn rồi đấy. Chứ hồi
trước nhá, vẫn bị tình trạng là các bạn
các bạn sinh viên học ở đại học xong vẫn
phải đi
học thêm ở các trung tâm các lò luyện
kiểu lò dạy nghề ấy một thời gian để có
thực sự có kinh nghiệm thực tế phải có
kiểu có một cái sản phẩm thực tế thì mới
đi phỏng vấn và có cái thứ để mà nói
được. Hồi trước là mình có biết hồi
trước là các bạn làm những cái đồ ăn tốt
nghiệp ở bên đại học và hình như bây giờ
vẫn còn đó là chỉ là những cái nghiên
cứu lý thuyết đương nhiên là mình không
thể phủ nhận được những cái đấy nó có
giá trị như thế nào. Thực ra là mình
không học vệ học nên mình không biết
nhưng
rất ít cái để mà demo được khi phỏng vấn
nói mấy cái đấy. Em đã nghiên cứu về cái
gì đó không em ạ? Chúng ta cần là có một
sản phẩm thực tế để biết rồi thực sự em
làm được có làm được đem lại giá trị gì
chứ không phải là em đã nghiên cứu được
cái gì. Đấy nghiên cứu để dèn tư duy rất
tốt nhưng mà không có một cái sản phẩm
nào để demo không sản phẩm nào để chứng
minh cả. Tất cả chỉ dừng trên lý thuyết
thì
à đấy bây giờ có AI ra rời rồi toàn bộ l
toàn bộ những cái lý thuyết chứng minh
của em có thể được viết bởi AI nên nó
càng không được đáng tin nữa
đấy nên là bây giờ thời đại giờ cạnh
tranh cũng sẽ khá gắt đấy đúng không ạ?
Các bạn phải cạnh tranh với không phải
cạnh tranh với AI đâu nhá. Rất nhiều
người vẫn thứ hay nói mình cạnh tranh
với AI. AI cướp Việt Nam mình không mà
là mình đang cạnh tranh với những người
biết dùng AI đấy. Na ná giống như là
thời của mình nhá. Thời của mình là mình
thường hay nói là nói với mấy bạn cùng
lớp luôn đó là ai mà Google tốt hơn.
Nghĩa là nắm được từ khóa để Google tốt
hơn nhá. Bởi vì nhiều bạn Google vẫn
bằng tiếng Việt. Mấy bạn không giỏi
tiếng Anh lắm, vẫn Google bằng tiếng
Việt là đã có kết quả lệch so với những
bạn biết tra cứu từ khóa, biết được đúng
từ khóa, tra bằng tiếng Anh rồi. Đấy,
đương nhiên bây giờ ai nó còn kinh khủng
hơn là thậm chí bạn trà tiếng Việt nó
vẫn ra kết quả. Đúng chưa ạ? Nó vẫn
hiểu. Trà tiếng Việt không giấu. Viết
tắt thì mình thỉnh thoảng có nhưng mà
chắc không đáng kể. Đấy, nhưng mà nó vẫn
tra được ra kết quả. Thì bây giờ mình sẽ
phải cạnh tranh như thế nào? Nó sẽ khốc
liệt hơn trước. Đấy. Nhưng có một sự
thật nha các bạn tra bằng tiếng Anh nó
vẫn sẽ ra kết quả tương đối khá khác so
với vạn tra tiếng Việt đấy. Cho dù cả
hai nó đều trả lời. Thứ nhất là AI nó
đôi khi không trả lời được nó sẽ thường
ấy bịa nên là nó khá là nguy hiểm. Thứ
hai đó là AI. Bây giờ theo như mình mình
không phải chuyên gia AI nên mình mới
gọi là đọc cứ cho là cưỡi ngựa xem hoa
biết qua đi thì mình vẫn nghe được đánh
giá là hoặc là chính cái hồi tin học à
đấy mình lôi ra kiến thức hồi mình dạy
tin học lớp 12 ra cho các bạn nhá. Đấy
bởi mình không học đại học cái này nên
mình không phải biết nhưng mà hồi mình
ngồi soạn đáp án lớp 12 học nhập môn AI
thì sẽ nói như này. AI bây giờ vẫn AI sẽ
được phân là hai loại là AI hẹp và AI
rộng.
À không phải rộng mà nó sẽ là
không biết dùng từ như nào nhưng mà
không phải hẹp nó sẽ là kiểu ai là hẹp
tức là nó sẽ chỉ chuyên sâu vào một lĩnh
vực nào đó thôi. Đấy còn AI toàn diện
gọi là ai gì sinh gì quên mất sử rồi
nhưng đại khái cứ cho rộng đi, trái
ngược với hẹp đi. Đi sẽ biết về mọi mặt
nghĩa là giỏi về mọi mảng. Đấy thì
AI bây giờ chưa
chưa phải là AI rộng, chưa đến được cái
ngưỡng AI rộng. Đấy nghĩa là vẫn là AI
hẹp, tức là nó sẽ chuyên sâu một mảng
nhất định. Đấy cái thứ nhất. Thứ hai đó
là
AI bây giờ vẫn sẽ được đánh giá là LLM
tức là Ledge
language model hay gì đó. Mình nhớ tiếng
Anh là thế.
Nó sẽ là kiểu ngôn ngữ lớn đúng không ạ?
Kiểu cái thế thì tức là sao? Nghĩa là
nó bản chất nó chưa đủ thông minh để
thực sự là hiểu, có tư duy để mà hiểu
mọi thứ hay để suy luận mọi thứ. Nếu mà
theo lý thuyết mà mình đọc đấy là nó
chưa nó chưa có đủ thông minh để mà suy
luận cái gì cả. Nghe có vẻ hơi vô lý. Rõ
ràng là các bạn sẽ phản bác ngay. Em hỏi
AI, AI còn lập luận mọi thứ bây giờ còn
có cả research này, xong rồi này hay mọi
thứ khác. Rõ ràng thấy nó thông minh mà
không, nó chỉ có đảo sâu hơn và tìm được
những cái từ thường hay đi với nhau
thôi. Tức là sao? Bây giờ giả sử là nó
học từ ngôn ngữ dĩ ở lớn, từ big data
đúng không? nó sẽ học rất nhiều
mọi thứ đăng trên mạng, mọi mọi thứ tài
liệu của nó có để biết được là từ này
hay đi với từ này. Nên là khi mà ông nói
một cái từ nào đó thì nó sẽ hiểu là ừ có
thể nó sẽ suy ra được từ này đi với từ
này sẽ ra kết quả như thế. Nó nó chưa đủ
thông minh để mà
kiểu suy luận được thực sự là bạn đang
muốn nói vấn đề gì đâu. Nó chỉ thấy là
từ này thường hay đi từ này nên nó sẽ
trả lời một cách kiểu ra được mực.
đoạn văn bản là như thế. Thế nên là tại
sao mình phải đề cập với việc này ở đây
và tại sao mình đề cập việc là mình tra
bằng tiếng Anh thì nó sẽ tốt hơn. Bởi vì
tức là sao? Nghĩa là mấy cái từ tiếng
Việt này
nó thường đi kèm với mấy cái từ tiếng
Việt khác đúng không ạ? Nghĩa là nghĩa
là kiểu các bạn hình dung là bây giờ bạn
muốn tra tài liệu nó lại quay lại câu
chuyện Google Search vừa nãy. Đây bạn
tra tài liệu bằng tiếng Anh thì rõ ràng
kết quả trả lời nó sẽ chính xác hơn. Thì
tương tự thế các bạn tra AI bằng tiếng
Anh nó sẽ ra được những cái tài liệu
bằng tiếng Anh
thì kết quả nó sẽ chính xác hơn so với
ra tài liệu bằng tiếng Việt. Nghe thấy
kiểu cũng hợp lý đúng không? Đương nhiên
là AI bây giờ nó có hỗ trợ dịch nhá là
nó có thể biến đổi ngôn ngữ của bạn sang
những cái khác nhưng mà thường là nó vẫn
sẽ ưu tiên với cái ngôn ngữ các bạn đang
tìm kiếm. Trừ khi các bạn ra lệnh nó là
đừng bao giờ tra tài liệu mọi thứ bằng
tiếng tiếng tiếng Việt mà tôi gửi bạn
nữa mà hãy tra cứu bằng những cái gì gì
đó. Đấy, thậm chí là có nhiều người cũng
từng công bố khẳng định rồi đến cả CEO
của
Open AI cũng từng nói rồi. Đó là nếu mà
các bạn dùng những cái từ của senior để
mà tra cứu thì nó sẽ trả về kết quả của
senior. Còn nếu mà các bạn mà nói với nó
bằng cái giọng của một junior hoặc kiểu
nói giọng bố đời hay gì gì đó vân vân
nói chung là kiểu cợt nhả gì đó thì nó
sẽ trả về kết quả bạn bởi những cái
người mà hay nói chuyện kiểu thếở trên
mạng và nó học được thì kết quả nó cũng
sẽ hơi cật nhả tí đấy kiểu thế nên là
thì như vừa nói đó là bây giờ thời đại
bây giờ là ai không dùng ai nó n giống
như ai không dùng Google ấy thì là một
kiểu mất đi một cái lợi thế. Còn nếu mà
mình dùng Google mà mình còn thông minh,
biết tra từ khóa, biết đúng được gọi là
từ khóa keyword hay mọi thứ thì nó sẽ nó
sẽ ra rất nhiều. Và gần đây mình cũng có
đọc một cái bài rất là hay nữa đó là à
các bạn chỉ nên tra AI khi mà các bạn đã
gần như là biết được câu trả lời rồi,
biết được đáp án rồi. Chẳng qua là bạn
có thể là không biết được là hướng đi
mọi thứ như nào hoặc là chỉ để kiểu xác
nhận lại xem đúng hay không hoặc là bảo
nó phản biện lại mình hay vân vân. Một
khi mà bạn không biết một cái gì cả, bạn
hỏi nó
thì bạn đang đúng kiểu đang giao tin
tưởng một cách hoàn toàn vào một
kiểu một con kiểu dạng nó có thể bịa ra
một cách rất là nghe phải rất là khoa
học, rất là hợp lý. Hồi trước đã từng có
vụ như thế nhá. Ờ hẳn về code nhá. Nó
chuyên về AI chuyên mạnh nhất về code.
Bởi vì sao? vì nó học tài liệu từ
từ code nó khá là đầy đủ và từng minh
code nó vẫn có logic nhất định trong đấy
nên là nó học từ cái đấy rất là tốt. Thì
có những con AI nó đã từng kiểu nó ra
được kiểu mình hỏi nó nhá nó ra kiểu gợi
ý ra một cái thư viện gì đó rồi nó code
các thứ thứ trông vẻ rất là xịn. Xong về
xong mới tra ra là cái thư viện đấy
không hề tồn tại luôn. Nó vừa bịa ra một
cái thư viện nào đó với đoạn code như
kiểu dạng là kiểu nó cốt ra ấy, nó phát
minh ra ấy hoặc có hiển nhiên tài liệu
về nó rồiấy. Không. Đấy. Thế mới nói là
đáng sợ nha. Hoặc là thằng đấy vừa
vừa để lộ lỡ hổng là một cái thư viện
nào đó nhưng mà dạng private nhưng mà nó
tiết lộ ra rồi anh em tra trên mạng
không ra. Cái đấy không biết được nhưng
mà nói chung là nó bịa ra rất là nguy
hiểm đúng không ạ?
ví dụ PP hay là ngôn ngữ khác thì đúng
là gần đây mình có hỏi là nếu giả sử mà
à giả sử mà mình không theo PP nữa mình
sang ngôn ngữ khác ví dụ giả dạng Java
hoặc là Python hoặc là Geng thì ngôn ngữ
nào phù hợp với cái trình độ của mình để
mình dễ chuyển sang bởi vì ừ thì mình
cũng cứ cho là có tuổi một tí rồi
Bây giờ 28 rồi à. Đây tôi không tính
tổng mụ đây ạ. Đấy thì à cũng có thể xác
lập gia đình trong một tương lai gần.
Đấy thì rõ ràng là mình không có thời
gian quá nhiều để ngồi cầy. Đấy mình sẽ
sang một ngôn ngữ nào đó để dễ dễ sang
hơn. Kết hợp việc là
à cái hợp việc là kiểu nói chung là thực
ra hơi tiếc về cái việc là mình đã có
nhiều năm kinh nghiệm và một cái ngôn
ngữ. Bây giờ sang cái khác thì mình chỉ
bê được cái tư duy lẫn cả nói chung là
vài cái thôi chứ còn về cái kiểu bởi vì
từ trước này tôi thường hay đi sâu và đi
sâu vào cả công nghệ của dụng PP các thứ
nữa thì sẽ không thể tận dụng được. Đấy,
kiểu mình kiểu cứ cho là mình cứ cho là
tầm master thì nó hơi quá nhưng mà mình
cũng khá thích PP với Larel nhiều rồi.
Bây giờ bảo sang PP thuần là thôi còn
ngại chứ đừng nói kiểu
đấy. Nhưng mà đúng là mình không nên gò
bó vào một chỗ như thế tự mình sẽ chôn
mình đúng không ạ? Đấy thì hôm đấy tôi
có tra thì chắc là Goang này nó sẽ khá
phù hợp để mà chuyển sang hơn.
Còn Java thì sẽ là một cái khó nhất này.
Java khó nhất này để mà chuyển sang.
Nhưng mà thực ra là chat tôi nhờ hôm đấy
là dùng cái
deep research của nó để nó phân tích kỹ.
Thì đương nhiên nó bảo Java nếu mà bạn
thích kiểu lập trình OP chặt chẽ như thế
thì lượng tuyển Java sẽ vẫn là đông
nhất. Đấy nhưng mà tuyển Java hôm trước
tôi ngồi nói này công ty nữa này.
B bây giờ là tôi bây giờ cứ cho là ở
công ty bây giờ cứ cho là đến cái ngưỡng
gọi là s nhá. Sino thì sẽ là tức là việc
gì cũng tạm thời có thể tự mình giải
quyết được. Đấy tự mình quyết định được.
Thì rõ ràng là khi mà đang là sino ở
công ty này, mình muốn sang công ty khác
thì mình không thể chuyển xuống thành
junior được. Mình vẫn phải giữ ở cái vị
trí tương đương ở senior sang công ty
khác đúng không ạ? Mà senior sang công
ty khác mà lại đổi ngôn ngữ thì đâu làm
sao làm seni được. Rõ ràng là đổi ngôn
ngữ là mình làm gì có rất nhiều cái mình
không tận dụng được. Mình phải ngồi học
lại nhiều cái mà. Đấy mà chuyển sang làm
Junior ở công ty khác này nó hơi bị
nó gọi như đã nếu mà bỏ qua về cái việc
cái tôi ra nhá thì nó cũng hơi bất ổn.
28 tuổi bây giờ mình tôi không nói nhiều
ông nhiều ông còn già lớn tuổi hơn tôi
bây giờ mới bắt đầu làm lập trình nhá.
Nhưng mà đang nói là kiểu khi mà đang
học tương đối ấy, bây giờ xa vào lại
quay lại Junio ấy nó kiểu bị
cắt ông cứ hình dung cắt đúng kiểu 1/3
ấy bị rõ ràng là 1/3 phải cả lương luôn
đấy. Nên là nó sẽ khá nhiều cái ờ cấn.
ơ thựt ra hồi trước tôi cũng từng chia
sẻ mặt lên rồi mà tôi có giấu mấy ông
đâu. Nick voer của anh là gì vậy ạ? Ờ
nick voer ácker lâu lắm rồi tôi không
vào. Thực ra hồi trước là tôi từng tạo
xong rồi tôi
không phải là cái username JTML đâu. NL
là từ hồi năm nhất đại học. Còn cái nick
vơ tôi tạo là từ 2
10 thì phải đúng nhở 10 12 gì đấy ngẫm
rất là lâu rồi hồi cấp ba
thế nên là
nick tôi cũng không tương tác mọi thứ
đâu. Bây giờ tôi chắc là lại chủ yếu là
thỉnh thoảng có vài anh em trên mấy cái
nhóm Facebook hoặc là trên fanpage
Facebook ấy
thì kiểu tôi thận tương tác trên đấy là
nhiều hơn.
Và kiểu anh em có thể chia sẻ mấy cái
bài từ
từ diễn đàn về thì tôi có vào đọc chứ
tôi không thường xuyên lướt trên diễn
đàn đọc nữa.
nhảy nhảy nhảy liên tục.
Đấy nói chung tôi trả lời được câu này
của bạn rồi đúng không ạ? Hi vọng bạn ấy
vẫn còn ở đây. Ờ còn những cái câu 2023
thì có thể bạn ấy vẫn còn ở đây. Có thể
bạn ấy sẽ xem lại. Tôi sẽ xóa bớt dần
đã. Tôi xin phép xóa dần. Nhiều quá
trông
lội tôi.
Ok.
cái để mấy ông hỏi đấy.
không? Ok. Tôi sẽ trả lời tiếp.
Mấy đó đã mấy đó là ví dụ hôm nay tôi
cũng thấy này có những người mà hồi
trước tôi từng theo dõi bây giờ đã lập
gia đình rồi đấy kiểu thế đã từng nói
chuyện
tương tác các thứ họ lập gia đình rồi
mình thì cũng có thể một tương lai gần
thôi một tương lai gần thì đấy rõ ràng
là
thứ nhanh phết hồi trước mà mình vẫn còn
còn gì ạ
Ờ
tóc này có thể sẽ rụng dần chuyển bạc
các thứ anh em. Lúc đấy mình sẽ chém gió
thác.
Hi vọng là không đã không đá sang chính
trị rồi.
Ờ đây tôi
sinh va em sinh viên năm đây. Thực ra là
tôi hơi kém cái khoản nhìn và đọc nên
tôi sẽ luyện dần. Em hiện tại sinh viên
53 em đang đi chuyên về dnet nhưng mới
học xát căn bản và một chút về không
biết. Nhưng em vừa làm một dự án mini
trên trường về web app code backend bằng
JavaSping thì thấy mình code Java ổn
định do có b sẵn nhưng trong lòng vẫn
muốn đi theo đet anh xin ý kiến hình như
là tôi từng trả lời câu này rồi đại khái
thì các bạn thích cái ngôn ngữ nào thì
cứ theo thôi không quan trọng việc
tương lai mọi thứ cái ngôn ngữ nào ổn
đâu. Bây giờ từ năm ngoái đến năm nay
đúng gần 1 năm rồi nhưng mà tôi hy vọng
là bạn đấy bây giờ đang theo Java ngon
hoặc là thích theo đét cũng được. Cả hai
đều là một cái khá là phổ biến.
Ok. Chào bạn hỏi đầu.
chứ tôi không xóa. Để tôi khôi phục lại
ạ.
trả lời rồi nhưng mà tôi ẩn đi.
Tôi tôi quên chữa ẩn mấy câu hỏi này tôi
trả lời rồi.
năm trước trả lời được mấy câu này hết
rồi mà.
Lừa thật đấy.
nhìn thầy trả lời hết rồi chứ.
PHP năm nào cũng sắp chết.
Ừ. Thực sự là tôi là người dạy PP. Tôi
không thể chê nó được. Mất miếng cơm
nhưng mà và cũng đang làm nó nữa. Nhưng
tôi có biết được những cái anh mà tôi
quen gần đây. Tôi không thể tiện nói tên
được. Nó vẫn nhạy cảm. Thì đúng là có
chuyển sang ngôn ngữ khác
nhưng mà họ vẫn có một lòng yêu Pep khá
mãnh liệt. Kiểu ở có cho là PP bây giờ
cứ ch kiểu yêu nó là đúng kiểu Trung
Thủy đi đấy. Nhưng mà đúng là Trung Thủy
bây giờ không
kiểu không bằng cơm áo gạo tiền nên là
vận chuyển sang ngôn ngữ khác có
nhưng không thể nói là nó là kiểu đến
ngày tàn được. Bởi vì tính ra thì tôi có
đọc rất nhiều bài kiểu nói tốt rồi. Cái
này thực ra các bạn nếu muốn thì các bạn
vẫn thể tra đọc được. Nên tôi chỉ thấy
là rất khó để mà nói về một ngôn ngữ.
Bây giờ trừ khi có mộtôn ngữ nữa giống
hệt nhưng mà tốt hơn hoàn toàn. Đấy chứ
còn bây giờ là rõ ràng là về hiệu năng
chẳng hạn nên các bạn sẽ không chọn PP
nhưng mà về dễ học thì sẽ Python PP vẫn
tính là một trong hai cái ngôn ngữ tương
đối là dễ học đấy vân vân nó sẽ có mỗi
cái thằng tôi thấy là mỗi thằng nó sẽ có
cái hay riêng tôi không học sang ngôn
ngữ khác kiểu chuyên về ngôn ngữ khác để
mà quay đi nói so sánh với PP được nên
là tôi chưa biết được ví dụ Ví dụ giả sử
là tôi học chuyên về Java lại quay lại
kiểu PP chẳng chặt chẽ gì cả. Lúc đấy
thì tôi sẽ có cái để nói vì tôi chuyên
cả hai rồi đúng không ạ? Bây giờ tôi
chuyên mỗi PP thì tôi thứ nhất là tôi
không thể chê được chính cái nồi cơm
mình đang ăn hàng ngày đúng không ạ?
Nhưng mà tôi và tôi cũng không biết chê
kiểu gì khi mà tôi không biết ngôn ngữ
khác là như thế nào đấy
nên là ừ 1 năm vừa qua thay đổi đúng
không? Tôi không vẫn PP vẫn trung thành
trung thủy đấy. Đấy mấy ông biết đấy. Ít
ra tôi cũng vẫn giữ được cái
gọi là cái của của gọi là cái chất của
bản thân. À ừ
Tôi nghĩ là cũng chẳng ảnh hưởng gì cả.
Ví dụ nhá. Hôm trước là tôi vừa dùng cái
argument tôi chẳng biết phát âm nó là
argument code để mà kiểu chat với nó
liên tục ấy. Không biết mấy ông biết
không? Chat nào liên tục thì nó sẽ ngồi
code nó sẽ đọc code cả project để mà
ngồi làm ra phần mềm. Thì tôi chưa giờ
tôi từng học Java trên trường nhưng mà
cứ cho quên hết rồi nhá. Tôi dùng nó
hoàn toàn tạo ra cái app.
App đấy không phải là app tá lả đâu nhá
mà app tính điểm chơi tá lả.
Đấy, kiểu thế thì
tận dụng chat liên tục với nó thì nó ra
đương nhiên có đến cuối thì nó vẫn phải
không thông minh lắm. Mình mất tận hai
ngày. Lúc ấy mình thấy là nó chỉ trống
ngầu thôi. Dù nó thông minh rất nhiều
nhưng mà nó code vẫn còn có quá nhiều
business nit, có quá nhiều logic là nó
sẽ không chặt chẽ ngay. Đấy và code thì
không clean tẹo nọ cả nên là nó sẽ nó sẽ
dễ thay thế với ông Junior chắc chắn là
đứt rồi. Bây giờ bảo AI giờ không thông
minh bằng ông Juno nữa thì thôi chẳng ai
dùng AI cả. Đấy nó sẽ code đến cận midle
các bạn. Nếu các bạn quên thì chúng ta
sẽ có Fer à intern fester xong rồi
junior xong rồi bây giờ mới đẻ gần đây
đẻ thêm cái middle đúng không ạ kiểu
giữa giữa xong mới đến senior đúng không
thì code của nó bây giờ đang cận là
middle tất cả nó sẽ giải quyết được rất
nhiều bài toán hơn của một
đấy kiến thức của nó là ba nhá nhưng nó
áp dụng vào thì bằng một ông midle rồi
nhưng mà để code hơn để dễ đọc hơn và để
mà thực sự là
có nhiều kinh nghiệm để mà đôi khi là
senior h hơn cái ống mí đồ chỉ dựa theo
kinh nghiệm thôi. Tức là chỉ là ông phải
biết trước được là đoạn nào nó sẽ dễ lỗi
để mà mình sẽ đẩy nó vào một cái chỗ nào
đó hợp lý để về sau mình dễ sửa, dễ đi
bấc chẳng hạn. Đấy thì rõ ràng là ông
Bíd đồ không như thế ông ấy kiểu làm cho
xong việc thôi nó sẽ khác đúng không ạ?
Đấy ch ông biết đồ hơn ông Jen ở điểm là
ông ấy chẳng cần phải hỏi gì cả. Ông vẫn
có thể làm được việc mỗi tội là việc đấy
là nó vẫn dễ phát sinh ra lỗi và rất khó
để sửa, rất khó để đọc. Còn nếu mà giả
sử mà dễ sửa dễ đọc thì thôi ông đấy lên
là senior rồi đấy. Nói thế đấy là đấy là
theo cách hiểu của mình đang hiểu.
Không biết có anh Sino nào vào chỉnh
mình không.
Nếu mà có xếp tôi ở đây chắc chắn anh ấy
sẽ chỉnh tôi đấy.
khung chat ạ. Nó sẽ là bạn ngại, bạn
không ngại thì bạn có thể hỏi ngay tại
đây cũng được, mình sẽ trả lời luôn. Còn
nếu mà bạn ngại muốn ẩn danh thì bạn sẽ
vào trong cái link kia chat cho nó sung.
Nhưng mà thực tế là
thực tế là các bạn hỏi luôn tại đây cho
nhanh cũng được.
code. Hôm trước tôi mở le code lên, mở
cả hacker rank lên luôn. List code thì
tôi mới đọc qua thôi. Thấy cũng đấy một
trang trông vẻ rất là hay để học.
Nhưng mà hôm hôm nay chưa nhá. mình kiểu
bây giờ não tầm giờ này là não tôi gạo
này sinh hoạt là kiểu cũng có cho là
điều độ nó không đúng hẳn nhưng mà nói
chung là nó cũng đã cố vào nề nếp là tức
cả sáng thì não tỉnh còn tối là não cũng
tắt đèn đi ngủ rồi tức là não không nghĩ
được nhiều đâu ạ nên là bây giờ bảo tôi
ngồi kiểu vận động não bây giờ để nghĩ
một cái gì đó thì
nó hơi gọi như
hơi kiểu
không thể dùng từ tốn chất xám được mà
cứ cho là hơi ngược đãi với não của mình
đấy.
Ờ
nhưng mà sẽ tôi hứa cái đấy và tôi vẫn
sẽ làm
sẽ thực ra hôm nay chưa là làm một cái
home để nói là khẳng định là tôi sẽ quay
trở lại livestream tiếp vì gần đây đúng
rồi tôi hôm nay tôi muốn nói đấy đó là
sau một năm qua tôi đã thay đổi rất
nhiều kiểu
thực tế đôi khi mình phải như thế tức là
ám chỉ là ví dụ hồi trước là tôi
livestream thường xuyên đúng không ạ
thực tế là hồi đấy là Tôi dành thời gian
việc ngày ngày code này tối về làm việc
khác hoặc livestream hay gì đó nhưng nó
sẽ nhược điểm là chưa chắc là mình tiến
bộ hơn mình chỉ làm cái gì đó đều đều
như thói quen hàng ngày thôi. Đấy hồi
đấy là tôi cũng nói cho các bạn những
cái mà cứ cho là những cái chắt lọc của
tôi thời đấy nhưng mà cũng hết thứ để mà
chắt lọc rồi đấy. Rõ ràng là mình sẽ
thành tán phép thực ra là nó không đem
lại được thêm giá trị gì mấy. Đấy thì rõ
ràng là sau một khoảng thời gian tôi
tự kiểu
à có cho là nâng thêm bản thân, tiếp xúc
nhiều hơn và cái chọn kèo mình cũng mở
lòng, mở cả não mở hết mọi thứ ra để mà
kiểu cố gắng hơn. Thì tôi cảm thấy là à
hôm nay tôi livestream trở lại cũng là
nó chẳng phải một cái dịp gì cả. thì để
nói là ừ thứ nhất là tôi vẫn
đang tốt lên và tôi muốn là giống như là
mình đang nói nãy giờ ấy nó là một sự
đồng hành theo kiểu là đây một cái kênh
là kênh chia sẻ góc nhìn cuộc sống của
một cái ông vơ một ông IT
96 phiên bản lỗi đúng không ạ 96 96 Bách
Hoa IT nhưng phiên bản lỗi tí đấy
để À các bạn thấy là chúng ta vẫn sau
một năm, sau một vài thời gian nhìn lại
chúng ta đã có vẻ trưởng thành hơn, suy
nghĩ nó sẽ khác đấy. Và mình nên như thế
chứ không phải là ông thì tiến bộ, tôi
thì vẫn chậm chân đấy. Kiểu thế không
nên thế.
Anh còn dùng chrome không? Tôi đang dùng
chom này. Cái này đang chom này. Đấy.
Sau khi nó đã không hỗ trợ manifest V2,
tôi cũng không biết cái Manifest V2 là
cái ảnh hưởng cái nào. Tôi nhớ hình như
là nó một phần nó liên quan đến việc
chạm quảng cáo nhưng mà thực ra tôi cũng
có dùng tài khoản YouTube a Premium nên
là được không để ý cái đấy lắm.
Không phải khoe gì đâu nhá. Nhưng mà cảm
thấy là ừ ý là chả cũng may mà bây giờ
mình đi làm. May bây giờ mình đi làm. Có
rất nhiều cái là tôi cảm thấy rất may mà
bây giờ mình
đã cũng tương đối đúng thời điểm. Đương
nhiên là có vài cái thì cảm thấy là nó
vẫn lệch thời điểm tí nhá. Ví dụ giả sử
nhá bây giờ có những phần mềm tôi thể tự
tin trả tiền được cho này. Ví dụ chat TV
chẳng hạn. Đấy vì may mình đi làm giờ
cái đấy nó không chiếm quá nhiều phần
trăm cái mức thu nhập mình thì mới có
thể trải được. Ok. Đấy chứ bây giờ kiểu
bây giờ tôi quay lại sinh viên thì chắc
là chỉ dùng mail do để cố mua mọi thứ có
thể miễn phí. Đấy. Thứ hai là may bây
giờ tôi đã học IT sớm hơn một vài bạn
nên thành ra là bây giờ vẫn an phận
được. An phận hiện tại vẫn đang ổn định
được. Nhiều bạn bây giờ vẫn còn đang
chơi vơi hơn này. Đấy nhưng mà không
đúng thời điểm một vài cái là ví dụ giả
sử bây giờ giá nhà giá mọi thứ nó tăng
vãi chưởng rồi. Tiền lương mình thì
không tăng kịp như thế. Rõ ràng là mình
sinh sau đẻ muộn mình không không có cái
gì cả. Đấy
nên cái đấy là bài toán về câu chuyện
khác. nó phải toán phải nhiều vấn đề lâu
dài nữa nên là tôi cảm thấy ý già tôi
vẫn may mắn
30 tuổi không phải là nói dễ sai thai.
Mọi không phải lúc với tôi không có khái
niệm thế nào là an toàn thực sự. Bất kỳ
lúc nào ông có thể bị sai thải. Quan
trọng là lúc mà ông sai thải ông làm gì
tiếp theo? Ông đã có những cái phương án
dự phòng cho mình chưa? Ông ví dụ ở gần
đây tôi có đây tôi chia sẻ thêm ông là
từ năm ngoài đến giờ tôi có đăng ký học
thêm tiếng Trung này thế cả cũng là để
đáp ứng được cái nhu cầu của tôi hồi
trước tôi từng nói không nhỉ kiểu tôi
muốn sáng chung để muốn khám phá xem là
bên đấy họ sinh sống mọi thứ như thế
nào, công nghệ họ là đi đến đâu vân vân
nói chung là cũng áp dụng cho sở thích
cá nhân chứ không hoàn toàn cho công
việc vì công việc thì rõ ràng trả liên
quan đến tiếng Trung À nhưng nói chung
là vẫn học thêm một cái gì đó nhá. Tiếp
theo là tôi cũng mới đăng ký cái lớp học
luyện thanh này đấy để mà mình sẽ nói
một cách kiểu tôi hy vọng là sẽ kiểu nói
về sau mà đi dậy hay là thậm chí về sau
làm diễn giả thì mình sẽ nói kiểu bớt
buồn ngủ hơn. Nói đều đều cử này có thể
hơi buồn ngủ vài ông đấy rõ ràng mình sẽ
nói chuyện cảm hứng hơn.
Đúng rồi, cũng có thể để ý hát nữa. Ông
này hiểu tôi vãi.
giỏi sau về năm kinh nghiệm. Ừ. Nhưng mà
đôi khi là chẳng cần nhất thiết phải sa
thải mọi thứ đâu. Mấy ông hãy nhìn là
gấp vộ kiểu tích cực đi. Tích cực ở đây
ể là công ty cho ông một cái cơ hội mới
để ông vùng ra. Mỗi tội là cơ hội đấy
lại cơ hội bóp ông bởi vì ông không vùng
ra được. Đấy cái là việc là đâu phải vấn
đề nằm ở ông đâu. Đôi khi là gần đây dự
án ở công ty tôi cũng có vấn đề này đấy
nghĩa là chuyện à công ty giả sử công ty
không còn sống được nữa thì ông cũng
phải nên đi chứ đúng không? Ông
thuyền chìm rồi đúng không ạ? Ông không
phải thuyền trưởng đúng không ạ? Thì ông
phải biết bơi chứ ông phải tự cứu bản
thân chứ đúng không ạ?
Đấy thì rõ ràng là
mình không nên cố tự chôn mình ở một chỗ
đúng không ạ? Mình mình gọi như này nà
với tôi quan điểm nhá là người giỏi là
người thả ở đâu sống được người ta sẽ
thích nghi rất tốt đấy chứ người mà chỉ
giỏi ở mỗi cái tại cái vị trí của người
ta đang ngồi còn khi mà tôi người ta ra
ngoài người ta biến thành con số không
thì đấy đâu phải là người giỏi đấy là
người kiểu may mắn người gặp thời chứ
thời khác cái là chết ngay thì không nên
đúng không ạ
em nhớ anh học cao đẳng đúng
Sau đó anh liên thân lại học đúng anh
học liên thông học đại học trong bao
nhiêu năm và học xong đại học lúc đó bao
nhiêu tuổi ạ? Ờ mãi về sau khi mà mình
tốt nghiệp xong một khoảng thời gian khá
là cũng tương đối thì mình mới đi học
liên thông. Mình học liên thông ở cái
trường cũng trường làng thôi. Nó cũng vô
danh nó cũng chẳng có gì cả nhưng mà nó
sẽ có cái M là bằng chính quyền bằng tại
tại chức hay gì bằng gì nhỉ? Đấy nói
chung bằng gì đóu đấy thì
học lúc đầu dự kiến là học trong 5 rưỡi
bao gồm chủ yếu là offline thứ bảy chủ
nhật nhưng mà cuối cùng thì do đ dịch
vân vân vân cuối cùng thành kéo này 2
năm hay 2 năm rưỡi gì đấy mới lấy được
cái băng ờ
cũng hình như là cũng 24 rồi đúng nhở
ra trường là năm 21 tuổi bởi vì học cao
đẳng nghề này sau đó thì 1 hoặc 2 năm
sau tôi mới bắt học này. Ừ chắc tầm 24
đấy.
nước khá nước nói khản giọng. Đợi tôi
một tí ạ. Để tí nhá.
quá. Không không, hôm nay đông ấy. Hôm
nay chắc chắn là có nhiều người kiểu tò
mò kiểu ơ lốt lắm rồi không gặp hai kiểu
ơ anh này lộ mặt này, anh này là vơ này.
Đấy kiểu thế chứ thực tế là hồii trước
lúc livestream đã từng có hôm mà kiểu
chưa đến 10 người mà
hôm nãy hồi đấy tôi đã từng hay nói rồi.
Đó là giả sử có mỗi một người xem rồi
tôi cũng sẽ nói thậm chí là không người
thì à không người thì sẽ có thể nói một
trong sự tuổi thân xong lúc sau tắt đi
không xóa video đâu. Bởi vì tôi biết là
kiểu gì mấy ông có nhiều người không vào
xem tại thời điểm trực tiếp đâu. Tôi nói
từ đầu video ấy có khá nhiều người tôi
thấy là lượng kiểu ví dụ bây giờ là hai
mấy người đúng không? Thì ông nghĩa lượt
xem nó sẽ cùng lắm là hơn trăm cộng với
tất cả những người nãy giờ đúng không?
Nhưng mà ông xem mấy video của tôi có
toàn vài trăm thậm chí là đến nghìn mà
thì rõ ràng là có nhiều người xem lại
này, có nhiều người kiểu mãi về xong mới
xem ấy. Đấy thì rõ ràng là mình vẫn
mình vẫn kiểu không vô hình đấy. Kiểu
thế tôi cảm thấy thế nên là mình
cứ đăng thôi. Có nhiều cái bài đăng tôi
đã từng đăng kiểu chẳng ai
không ai thì nó không đúng.
Like thích thôi tôi sẽ không dùng từ
like thích dùng từ tương tác đi. Không
có ai tương tác có mình trông hơi xấu hổ
tí nhưng mà
tôi muốn tính tôi là thích chia sẻ. Tôi
sẽ chia sẻ để cho cảm thấy là những ai
mà thấy có tí trùng quan điểm họ sẽ cảm
thấy là ừ có người đồng cảm đấy chứ
không phải là vì tôi tất nhiên ai cũng
có nhu cầu muốn được lắng nghe nhá.
Nhưng không phải là vì tôi cảm thấy là
tôi làm thế này để mà
kiếm thêm nhiều người xem hay là cắm này
làm thế này để nâng cao cái giá trị của
bản thân lên không. Bởi vì nếu mà làm
thế có sẽ rất nhiều cái cách và thậm chí
là làm lố bản thân cũng có. Tôi không
hướng đến kiểu thế. Rõ ràng là cái kênh
tên là blog mà tất cả anh chị mình sẽ
blog ông mấy ông mà hồi chơi Yahu trước
hay các thứ sẽ biết cái từ này khá nhiều
hơn. Hồi trước tôi từng cân nhắc việc
làm vlog hay blog. Rõ ràng nó vẫn là
video nhá nhưng mà là blog bởi vì sẽ còn
đăng những cái khác không phải mỗi
video.
Nó làm những cái câu chuyện, những cái
suy nghĩ hàng ngày cũng có hoặc là đôi
khi không phải hàng ngày. Vlog hồi trước
là tôi nhớ là tôi đọc cái khái niệm ấy ở
trên một cái trang báo nào đó thì là
vlog là cần những cái video daily à
những video hàng ngày về cuộc sống người
ta không. Tôi không muốn kiểu thế. mà sẽ
là
mà sẽ là kiểu một cái
cuốn nhật ký thì nó không đúng nhưng mà
sẽ cuốn tự sự là nhiều hơn. Thỉnh thoảng
mình sẽ chia sẻ những câu chuyện của bản
thân hoặc là mình nhìn thấy theo góc
nhìn theo góc đánh giá của bản thân
mà với hy vọng là chia sẻ nó có một cái
lợi ích gì đó không phải mỗi tính chất
giải trí
nổi. Thực ra anh cũng từng quen những
cái người à không hỏi quen mà có biết
một vài kênh kiểu họ cũng ạc nhiên khi
mà kênh họ nổi. Gần gần đây nhất anh có
nghe thật ra là lần phải gần đây nhất
phải lần cuối có nghe thì nó têu phạm
chẳng hạn. Ông ấy anh ấy cũng là một anh
kiểu chỉ muốn nói ra những cái suy nghĩ
của bản thân và ông ấy anh ấy theo như
anh ấy nói thì anh ấy cũng bảo là không
hướng đến việc mình là người nổi tiếng
không muốn nhiều người kiểu thích mình
đến thế là kiểu thế cũng nói mình là một
người kiểu cũng bất cân cũng kiểu rất
nhiều cái nhược điểm mọi người đừng coi
anh đấy là một cái thần tượng thần thánh
gì đó thật ra tôi cũng không thân tượng
anh đấy có nghe vài video của trước thôi
đấy nhưng mà em chị ở đấy một cái hay
tôi có theo dõi nhiều kênh lắm để mà
kiểu
tôi sẽ kiểu sẽ thắc mắc ấy kiểu có nhiều
kênh thậm chí có chục người theo dõi tại
sao họ vẫn đăng video đấy kiểu thế chục
người theo dõi đấy nhá chứ không phải là
của tôi là đến nghìn người theo dõi hồi
đế kiểu đúng là được J2 team community
kiểu tương tác cho kiểu bấm và theo dõi
cho chắc là đôi khi là đa số là cho có
thôi nghĩ là mình rồi mình sẽ xem thì
thự ra không xem đấy nhưng mà
thấy nó vẫn còn hơn rất nhiều người
nhiều người tôi biết là kiểu chục người
theo dõi họ vẫn đang đều ở ni để mà kiểu
sẽ một ngày nó nổi lên thôi không sao
thậm chí là họ làm với mục đích tương
lai để kiếm một cái đồng tiền từ từ nền
tảng này tôi thì thực ra là chia sẻ vì
tôi thích thế nó đam mê không phải kiếm
tiền nữa.
Ôi nay có mặt. Uây có vài lần tôi nhớ
tôi có đăng mặt rồi mà. Tôi có giấu mặt
đi đâu nhỉ? Có ảnh đại diện của tôi thì
đúng là kiểu kia. Ảnh đại diện tôi tôi
hướng đến ấy nó là thể hiện việc là các
bạn nó là những dòng code những dòng
code đầu tiên của tôi đấy.
Code đầu tiên nó không đúng. Code đầu
tiên à là pasc mất rồi. Code đầu tiên
mình cứ cho là hồi học lập trình kiểu
thực sự thích lập trình đi. Đấy những
dòng code đầu tiên tôi và cái việc là
trông nó cũng ngầu trông nó cũng kiểu
dạng là kiểu dạng giống kiểu anonymus à
không phải nói giống Anonymus nhưng mà
anh chị ạ. Nó sẽ nó là kiểu anonymus
dịch ra là kiểu ẩn danh ý. Kiểu nó là
tôi muốn là kiểu dạng là muốn nói theo
góc nhìn danh chứ không phải là cụ thể
đại diện cho một ai.
list PP cho một repo nhá. Ồ
được đề xuất bởi một cái repo nào đó
trên cái h cũng xịn
chắc là không biết tôi đã từng tương tác
cái ripo nàyấy chưa nhưng mà có vẻ là
kiểu tôi cũng từng hình như ở trong team
community từng chia sẻ mấy cái repo về
kiểu học lập trình miễn phí rồi không
biết là tôi đã từng tương tác vào đấy tự
đề xuất bản thân chưa nhưng mà
thực tế là nói chung là tôi đã từng nói
cái này nhiều lần rồi tôi xin phép nhắc
lại lần nữa.
là bây giờ để mà xem lại những video cũ
tôi cảm thấy là đáng lẽ tôi có thể dạy
được tốt hơn. Đáng lẽ là kiến thức của
tôi đến bây giờ thay đổi nhiều kiến thức
kiểu tốt hơn rồi mà tôi thể quay lại
code kiểu quay lại dạy các bạn xịn hơn.
hơi tiếc hơi tiếc cho những cái bạn đã
từng học của tôi. Xin chưa buồn là hồi
đấy bây giờ tôi mới trưởng thành hơn để
mà có thể
có thể dạy được các bạn thì các bạn đã
mọc đủ lốc đủ cánh để bay mất rồi. Hoặc
là quá tuổi. Không phải nói quá tuổi
nhưng mà nó là kiểu gì ạ?
Quá lứa à? Ừ. Đấy, bây giờ lứa mới rồi.
Thực ra bây giờ tôi cũng chưa quay lại
để biến thành một lứa mới nữa. Nhưng mà
đấy sau rất nhiều thời gian tôi học hỏi
cho dồi hơn thì tôi cảm thấy là
chắn rất là xịn để mà
tôi soạn giáo án chuẩn trì cực. Hồi mà
tôi làm tuyển sinh bên tuyển sinh tôi
soạn giáo án rất là chuẩn chỉ luôn.
Những cái mà các bạn đã từng bị thiếu
sót tôi sẽ cố bù đắp hết. Soạn giáo án
này à bài tập này đấy. Xong rồi các thứ
thứ xịn lắm
nghe rất hứa hạnh cứ hứa thôi. Hứa là
cái thứ dễ dễ mà.
mới như bán hàng online không?
Nó chưa giờ suy nghĩ đấy. Tôi từng suy
nghĩ việc là về sau giả sử mình thành
người nổi tiếng thì
à kiểu
người nổi tiếng Koo khác thì sẽ là AFS
hay quảng cáo một cái gì gì đó để mình
ăn gì hoa hùng gì đó. Tôi đã từng nghĩ
thế không? Tôi tôi không phải tôi nghĩ
là tôi sẽ làm thế nhá mà tôi từ nghĩ tôi
có làm thế không là kết quả là không.
Tôi không có ý định làm mấy cái thứ mà
những cái khác hiện tại đang làm. Tôi
không hể nói là họ đang làm đúng hay sai
nhưng đang nói là kiểu tôi không thích
kiểu thế.
Bởi vì tính ra có những cái hồi trước có
người nói vậy đó kiểu
những cái gì là đam mê của bạn mà dình
và đồng tiền ấy thì nó sẽ đi kèm với
trách nhiệm rất nhiều thứ nữa. Nó không
thực sự còn là đam mê nữa sẽ kiểu bị
nhiều cái nó ảnh hưởng
ảnh hưởng rất nhiều. Vì về sau mình sẽ
không nói chuyện một cách thoải mái được
nữa. Mình sẽ kiểu phải cân nhắc hơn rất
nhiều khi nói.
À đấy là mẹ tôi đây. Mẹ tôi kiểu tóc bạc
rồi. Mẹ tôi cũng
có tuổi rồi. Tôi hôm trước tôi nghĩ là ừ
hình như là bây giờ mẹ cũng đụng tầm tầm
tuổi này mẹ tôi cũng mới bắt đầu có tôi.
Tức cảm chỉ là mẹ tôi bây giờ đang gấp
đôi tuổi tôi đấy. Thế nên là cũng có
tuổi nên cũng
tóc bạc các thứ. Mẹ cũng nhuộm theo kiểu
theo kiểu lạ nữa. Đây hai team community
cũ còn cứu được không anh? Ừ gần đây tôi
có lại suy nghĩ lại việc đấy.
Thực ra là mới thấy là đúng là mình cũng
hơi thấp cổ bé học theo kiểu là hồi
trước là đến cả chính nick Facebook của
tôi tôi mất rất lâu thì mới nhờ anh
Chicker để mà hỗ trợ. dịch vụ để lấy
lại. Mà bây giờ anh Mạnh Tuấn thì anh ấy
sẽ không tin tưởng ai để mà trao thông
tin hay là trao tài khoản đưa cho các
bạn trích cơ để mà lấy lại hay vân vân
nên là càng càng rất khó. Còn nếu mà các
bạn tricker nào có tâm để mà kiểu gửi
gửi chọn kiểu gọi là
hỗ trợ nhóm đặc biệt miễn phí nữa nhá
thì
đáng nẽ mấy bạn đấy sẽ phải làm rồi
nhưng có vẻ là tôi đang thấy đây là một
là đây là ca khó hai các bạn ấy sẽ không
cảm thấy không muốn làm nên thành ra là
mang tiếng là J team Community là một
cộng đồng lớn một cộng đồng
có nhiều dân công nghệ nhưng mà có Phải
là khi bị cái gì đó thì mọi người đang
học cách chấp nhận nó. Và tính ra thì
mình vẫn là ư kiểu gọi nhở mình vẫn là
người dùng nền tảng thôi.
Mình mình không thể chống lại có hồi
trước từng bị bay đây là lần thứ ba với
chứ.
Nói chung là kiểu cũng khó
nhóm như thế thì không miễn phí được
đâu. Thì đấy thì mình đã nói là là nó có
ý nghĩa như nào với mọi người để mà mọi
người làm chứ rõ ràng thì
anh Tuấn thì à làm nhiều cái đương nhiên
là cũng sẽ có gần đây gần đây còn được
gọi là được lợi nhiều hơn bởi vì là còn
có thêm cả nhiều mảng khác nữa.
Còn tôi thì tôi hồi trước là tôi làm mọi
thứ
đương nhiên là mục đích ban đầu là vì
đam mê vì có tâm về sau tự các vẫn thế
nhưng mà tôi đúng là tôi cũng được lợi
thêm rất nhiều từ nhóm đây ví dụ giả sử
được gặp các ông cũng là một trong cái
được nhiều người biết đến là một trọng
cái. Thậm chí hồi trước cũng a
cũng thượng đẳng đi, nói thẳng là cũng
thượng đẳng. Hồi đấy là đúng là kiểu
thủng thùng rỗng không phải thùng rỗng
cây to đâu. Đấy dùng từ x ngồi đáy giếng
hơn là kiểu hồi đấy khá là không phải là
coi mình hơn người đâu nhá. Chỉ đơn giản
là cảm thấy mình có tiếng nói nên là sẽ
nói chuyện nó khá là
kiểu dạng là bất cần ấy, người khác cần
mình đấy. Kiểu thế thành ra mình sẽ nói
chuyện kiểu khá khó chịu. Tôi nhiều lúc
tôi có xem không phải nói là xem nhắn cũ
vì rất nhiều người đã từng nhắn tin cho
tôi đặc biệt là nhắn tin nhờ hỗ trợ hồi
đặc biệt hồi làm kiểm duyệt hay các thứ.
Nên là đúng kiểu là lúc đấy là bởi vì
mình cũng kiểu dạng là
ai nhắn mình nghĩa vụ của mình thực ra
không phải giúp đỡ người ta nên thành ra
đặc biệt trong cái nội quy của nhóm có
ghi ấy ba kiểu diệt không có nghĩa phụ
là phải trả lời hỗ trợ qua tin nhắn đấy
nên thành ra là kiểu c đấy kiểu mình
hứng lên thì mình trả lời hứng không thì
mình sẽ nói chuyện kiểu đọc khó chịu
thật đấy.
là tôi cảm thấy là cũng may cũng may là
khi mà mình đã nhận thức được những cái
điều đấy. Đấy
bão wif vô Hà Nội máy thế hôm à đâu sáng
mai có kèo cà phê với anh em ở Hà Nội.
Hi vọng sáng mai không sao. Còn
còn chiều mai thì không có lịch này, còn
cuối tuần thì lại có lịch tiếp. Ừ cũng
nói chung là gần đây tôi khá nhiều lịch
bận rộn hơn khá nhiều nên thành ra là
tôi hướng đến
là tôi hướng đến là cái kiểu dạng là
mình sẽ
tranh thủ rất nhiều cái nên thành ra là
cũng tự sắp xếp bản thân mình bận thật.
Trải nghiệm của người có chức có quyền
sao đạ?
cảm thấy là đúng là mình từng đi vào cái
gọi là ai rồi sẽ trở thành con người
mình ghét. À không biết thế đúng không?
Nhưng mà tôi có cái ảnh hồi trước cho
chính tôi đăng để nói về người khác
nhưng mà nó sẽ về sau tôi thấy nó với
tôi đó là cái ảnh tôi để trong cái album
poser của tôi. Đó là cái gì nhỉ?
người
để đánh giá một người ấy là khi mà tôi
tôi không nhớ được chính xác câu ấy văn
vở như nào đâu nhá nói đại ý nhá là để
đánh giá một người ấy là khi mà người ta
có
khi mà họ cũng có quyền lực ấy thì sẽ
đánh giá được người đấy bởi vì ví dụ nhá
ví dụ nhá đã từng có rất nhiều người
thường hay nói là người này hiền thế hay
người này kiểu
ngoan hay vân vân một cái gì đó người
tốt thế đấy bởi vì Vì thực á họ không có
gì trong tay cả. Họ không không có đủ
điều kiện để mà đe dọa hay là để làm tổn
thương một ai cả. Đấy ông ông hiểu ý tôi
không? Thế bây giờ giả sử mà họ có chức
có quyền hay họ có tiền chẳng hạn liệu
họ có làm phiền thêng hạ không hay họ
vẫn sẽ sống như thế? Đương nhiên là cái
đấy là nó chỉ là giả thuyết nên không ai
thể
chứng minh hay mọi thứ được. Nhưng là ý
tôi là kiểu thế rất khó đánh giá một
cách công bằng được cái bản chất của họ
có thực sự liên thiện hay không. Mình
chỉ biết được là trong cái hoàn cảnh này
tại thời điểm hiện tại họ đang là người
tốt hoặc họ không có cái điều kiện để
thành người xấu. Nó là giống như là hồi
trước tôi xem cái thỏ bảy màu à hoặc có
vài người từng nói kìa trong cái video
của thỏ bò m bảy màu kìa. Ông kia bị bồ
bị bạn gái chia tay ấ s kiểu ông ấy nói
nhưng mà anh tốt mà. Đấy kiểu thế.
Kiểu tuy là em anh nghèo nhưng mà anh
tốt đấy anh ơi. Thì đấy là con đường duy
nhất của tàn cái của mấy ông nghèo mà
anh cay nhưng mà chưa à kiểu người giàu
người ta vẫn có thể là người tốt mà. Ừ
thì rõ ràng mình có ưu điểm gì hơn người
ta không đúng không ạ?
mình làm gì có điều kiện để trở thành
người xấu đâu. Đấy nên là sẽ không thể
nói họ là người tốt được. Họ chỉ đang
gọi là họ đang là chính mình là phiên
bản tốt ở trong điều kiện hiện tại của
họ chứ họ chưa chắc phải là người tốt
hoàn toàn. Thế kiểu thế tôi nói thế tôi
không biết là có đánh đồng với cả tôi
không. Tôi tôi thì tôi không thấy nhột
đâu. Tôi cũng chưa nhận tôi là người tốt
bao giờ. Tôi chỉ thấy là tôi đã may mà
tôi đã cố cố đến thời điểm hiện tại tôi
vẫn khẳng định là tôi vẫn đang cố không
bị mấy cái khác làm tha hóa. Đấy kiểu
thế có chức có quyền kia thì tôi chưa
biết nhá. Nhưng mà ấy ra về
à tư bản à tư bản vẫn chưa khiến tôi
thao hóa, chưa khiến tôi sao đọa đấy,
chưa khiến tôi bị sau đó tôi cảm thấy
rất là may mắn khi mà tôi chưa bị một
cái đấy làm áp lực khi nó mình kểu phải
đắn đo cân nhắc giữa lương tâm với cái
gì đó. Đấy kiểu thế.
cún trong nhà không? Em cún vừa chạy nấy
giờ đây. Đấy h nếu mà thực ra từ trước
nay tôi thường hay nuôi chó mèo kiểu à
đặc biệt là nuôi cún nó sẽ dễ hơn với
góc nhìn tôi vì tính em phải khá giống
kiểu một đứa trẻ con mình luyện luyện
nuôi nó thì mình sẽ về sau học cách để
mà
kiểu đương nh một phần thôi nhá một phần
thôi nhá trẻ con nó nhiều phức tạp hơn
máy tính anh nghĩ có nên mua mua lướt
không? Mua lướt tức là mua hàng dùng rồi
đúng không? Thậm chí hàng hết bảo hành
rồi đúng không? Thì cá nhân tôi
cá nhân tôi từ trước nay nếu mà bởi vì
tính ra mình cũng
có điều kiện một cách tương đối là thành
ra là toàn mua rất điểm một cái máy mới
hẳn. Máy hiện tại ra là không hẳn là mới
hẳn. Máy hiện tại là nó cứ cho còn
nguyên hộp L new 99% hay gì đó.
Nhưng mà đúng là
máy mới hẳn có nguyên hộp còn còn bảo
hành mình sẽ có yên tâm khá là nhiều.
Còn nếu mà mình không có tài chính th là
mình phải chấp nhận thôi. Đấy đó là bài
toán chấp nhận đúng không ạ? Còn rất còn
à tôi nghĩ là nó sẽ
khá hạn chế việc mua trả góp một cái gì
đó. Tôi đã từng mua trả góp một cái gì
đó. Thức cái cái đấy chính cái tôi mua
trả góp lại cái bất ổn đó là kiểu nó bị
lỗi các thứ thứ. Đương nhiên là vẫn có
bảo hành nhá nhưng mà đâu nói là kiểu
trả góp nó đâu khiến cho mình à an tâm
hơn phần nào đâu. Mình lo lắng hay mình
còn thấy khó chịu hơn trong thời gian
mình trả góp nghĩa là đấy nó bị hỏng.
Xong rồi mình còn cảm thấy là mình đang
trả tiền món đồ hỏng đấy. Mình còn đang
chật vật trả tiền món đồ hỏng đấy. Nên
tính ra thả
thả mua một cái gì đó kiểu nó không có
không thể nói là không mua một cái không
bảo hành được nhưng nó th mua một cái gì
đó trong tầm tiền mình. Đấy, xong mình
về sau mình có thể lấy cái cớ là với cái
tầm tiền này thì nó chỉ có thế thôi
chứ bây giờ ông mua cố mua một cái xịn.
Tôi đã từng nghĩ rất nhiều về vụ đấy
nhá. Mua ít nhất là về máy tính Windows
nhá. Mua xịn đến mấy mua hàng. Tôi từng
mua Thp này. Nó cũng tính là một cái
không phải máy chạm nhưng mà máy cũng
kiểu bền này đúng không? từng mu máy
chạm đeo ở niề sau một th sau hai ba năm
nó vẫn tạ đấy lúc ấy tôi cảm thấy mất
niềm tin vãi chưởng c
máy máy rõ ràng mình bỏ đầu tư vào nhiều
thì rõ ràng mình nghĩ là nó sẽ ổn định
và lâu dài nhưng không
có gì khẳng định điều đấy cả đặc biệt là
đặc biệt là thường nó chỉ xảy ra sự cố
sau khi hết bảo hành nên là càng thấy
kiểu cảm thấy bỏ hành như một cú lửa nên
hồi trước hình như là tôi đã từng
livestream
cũng nói xấu về cái bên đấy một lần thôi
nên thôi tôi sẽ không nói lại nữa. Nhưng
ông hiểu ý tôi không?
Bây giờ ông mua là để phục vụ cho nhu
cầu của ông. Ông ông mua một cái gì đó
tính ra cái nào cũng là tiêu sản nhưng
mà nó đem lại được những cái giá trị
thuyết thật bù lại giá trị không? Ví dụ
giả sử ông cần máy để để đi làm bây giờ
luôn thì ông mua luôn ông chẳng cần phải
suy nghĩ gì cả. Đấy cần máy để học đúng
không? Cũng cũng cần. Bây giờ cần gấp
đúng không? Mua thôi. Đấy không cần phải
quá suy nghĩ về quá nhiều về cái đấy.
Còn nếu mà ông tính về lâu dài thì kiểu
là muốn mua cái đồ công nghệ này để dùng
trong chục năm nữa thì nói thẳng luôn là
chẳng có cái đồ công nghệ nào bây giờ đủ
bền để cho chục năm nữa cả. cả máy tính
cả điện thoại hay mấy cái khác nên là kẻ
máy cây luôn đấy nên là
không tính lâu dài được đến thế hãy tính
xem là nó đem lại được ông bao nhiêu giá
trị nó có đáng hay không đấy thế thôi.
Thế nên là rõ ràng nếu mà tính như tôi
vừa tính vừa rồi thì mấy ông có khi là
không chọn một cái đồ đắt giống như tôi
đã từng mà chỉ chọn một cái giá hợp lý
với thời điểm hiện tại đúng không ạ? Đấy
10 triệu bây giờ cũng có tầm 10 10 đến
20 triệu bây giờ cũng có cái để hoàn
toàn ổn để dùng ổn định đúng không ạ?
Bởi vì hồi trước đã từng dạy sinh viên
kiểu thế đó là sinh viên năm nhất năm
hai không có tiền. Giả sử chưa có laptop
mua con laptop cũ để mà mình học trong
thời gian học à cứ cho là hẳn 4 năm học
đại học đi. Đấy xong rồi khi mà lần lần
đầu đi thực tập có tiền lương cái đổi
con máy luôn. Thế là xong.
Đấy là một kiểu mà
cần máy chơi game thì sao? Anh
mày chơi game thì nó có thể đem lại cái
giá trị giá trị tinh thần đúng không ạ?
Nhưng giá trị tinh thần là một thứ không
thể đong được nên là thành ra là
rất khó để mà xác định được là cái giá
trị em đang cần những cái giá trị tinh
thần như thế nào. Giả sử là giả sử là
anh thì anh chơi game ở nhà không hẳn là
nhiều lắm. Hồi trước anh toàn đi nét với
anh em vì giá trị thần của anh là chơi
với bạn bè anh em. Rõ ràng là anh chẳng
cần phải mua máy chơi game gì cả. Đấy.
Còn nếu giả sử em thích ở nhà, em thích
chơi game em và bố mẹ em bắt em ở nhà
vân vân gì đấy chẳng hạn thế đúng không?
Đấy thì rõ ràng là đấy ví dụ giả sử bố
mẹ em bắt em ở nhà chỉ được chơi ở nhà
thì bảo bố mẹ đầu tư cho suy nghĩ làm gì
đấy. Còn nếu giả sử mình muốn mua một
cái máy để mình ở nhà làm việc và thỉnh
thoảng chơi game đó thì rõ ràng là nó
vẫn phải hướng đến làm việc đúng không
ạ? phải phù hợp để làm việc. Chơi game
là yếu tố phụ. Còn nếu giả sử mà ông chỉ
mua máy chơi game thôi đúng không? Thích
chơi game ở nhà thôi đúng không? Đấy thì
nó lại phù phụ thuộc vào việc ông sẽ
chơi game gì đấy. Ông chơi game offline
hay online? Đấy offline thì sẽ cần cấu
hình như thế nào đấy và vẫn phải cân
nhắc về cái điều kiện kinh tế của ông.
Nói chung là có rất nhiều cái câu mấy
ông đang hỏi. Hồi trước là tôi thường
hay bảo là trao Google đi. Bây giờ AI
thông minh hơn rồi. Tôi sẽ hỏi ông là
ông sẽ bảo tôi sẽ bảo ông là dùng ai để
hỏi để trả lời đi. Đây tôi sẽ thử trả
lời luôn ông. Thử thử nhá. Tôi mở cái
này lên có lý do đấy. Đấy
có bạn hỏi tôi mua máy tính chơi game
thì lựa máy thế nào? Giả sử laptop nhá.
À thôi cứ hỏi thế này thôi. Xong rồi nó
sẽ luôn hỏi lại ông những cái câu để ông
sẽ nói rõ hơn cái điều kiện của ông, rõ
hơn ngữ cảnh. Đấy, ví dụ là cần laptop
hay là cần máy cây, cần máy trong tầm
tiền bao nhiêu đấy, vân vân mọi thứ như
nào đấy. Đấy, luôn câu đầu tiên này, xác
định nhu cầu trước khi mua đúng không?
luôn cái đầu tiên chơi game gì này đấy.
Muốn chơi mượt hay không này. Kiểu ví dụ
tôi này, tôi dùng con máy này tôi chơi
game
2 m đôi khi là nó cũng giật giật nhưng
mà tôi chấp nhận ấy kiểu thế nhưng nhiều
người không chấp nhận nhiều người kiểu
cấn cấn tí kiểu màn hình phải tần số
quét cao. Màn hình tôi hiện tại đang tần
số quét đúng bằng con điện thoại tôi 60
60 thôi. Em chỉ không cần.
quen thế. Ui mấy bạn bây giờ nhiều bạn
tôi trồng quen cực.
Nhưng mà tôi sẽ không nhớ mấy ông đâu.
Mấy ông phải gặp tôi ít nhất một lần
ngoài đời tôi mới nhớ. Tôi không giỏi
nhớ tên người khác lắm. Tôi sẽ giỏi nhớ
mặt và tính cách hơn.
ạ cũng được kể cả mua mới thì đôi khi
bây giờ tôi vẫn sẽ đề xuất là MacBook
nếu mà thiên về lập trình hay là nói
chung là những cái tác vụ nó không không
yêu cầu là phải cài phần mềm ở trên
Windows bởi vì đúng là MacBook ổn định
nhưng mà và nó sẽ không bị sẽ nhanh hỏng
các thứ
nửa màn hình nhở bởiì hôm nay tôi muốn
là để cho mấy Mấy ông a
mang tiếng là tâm sự thì mấy ông cần cái
mặt cần nhìn mặt đấy như vẻ bây giờ đến
cái đoạn tra thì thôi. Ờ anh chỉ dùng
chat GVT thôi ạ. Tôi dùng qua chat GVT
Germany thôi. Vứt đi nhá. Gerini tôi
chưa dùng bản pro nhưng J nói chung rất
tệ. Copilot thì tôi từng dùng cũng từng
dùng kể cả copilot mới hay là cũ nó vẫn
tệ nên thôi.
Ừ code initer cũng dùng rồi này. Tab
tabline à tabline bỏ qua lâu lắm rồi.
Dùng Cor, dùng Winsert, dùng argument
code mấy cái đấy thì vẫn là chỉ phù hợp
code thôi, không nói chuyện được gì mấy.
Dùng tôi thường dùng Grock nữa. Cloude
thì tôi chưa dùng bao giờ nhưng mà tôi
dùng Grock nữa. Grock thì tôi thường hay
đối chiếu kết quả với thằng CH GVT chứ
tôi thì tôi mua tài khoản chaity và tôi
thấy chatt cá nhân hóa rất tốt rồi nên
là tôi sẽ không có
tôi thấy mấy con kia chữ cá cá nhân hóa
tốt bằng ấy kiểu nó ghi nhớ lịch sử và
nó cá nhân hóa nó trả lời mọi thứ nó rất
là phù hợp với mình rồi tội gì.
Còn để mà đánh giá so với con khác như
thế nào thì đấy như tôi vừa nói nó đáp
ứng được đúng nhu cầu của tôi. Đấy tôi
có cái mấy cái ví dụ là tôi tạo ra con
để mà soạn tài liệu dạy này, trả lời
fanpage này. Hô đấy còn để luyện học
tiếng Trung này, trả lời Google Map này,
chơi 2 này. Đấy, nghĩa là gợi ý đồ rồi
gợi ý cách khắc chế. Đấy, kiểu nó rất là
phù hợp với nhu cầu mình rồi nên là mình
chẳng có nhu cầu gì thêm cả.
á? Hay là như nào nhỉ?
conâ đấy với AI ấ sẽ trả lời cho ông.
Tôi đã từng dùng chính mấy con AI để tự
đánh giá chính nó rồi.
hồi mà dạy SQL SQL tôi vẫn công nhận là
hồi đấy tôi đã dạy rất có tâm rồi. Cho
dù về sau tôi nhận ra là có vài cái tôi
vẫn có thể cải thiện hơn được. Cái gì
cũng có thể cải thiện được. Nghĩa chứng
tỏ trình độ mình lên rồi đúng không? thì
mình mới cảm thấy kiểu khối trước cái
mình dạy chưa chuẩn chỉ
mấy cái trợ lý kia tôi đang dùng bản
chativity plus đúng rồi plus nên là sẽ
cho ông có thể tạo ra những cái con GBT
nữa để nó sẽ hỗ trợ chuyên vào những cái
lĩnh vực mà ông muốn đế đương nhiên là
tôi thấy là một cách tương đối thôi
nhưng mà nó và nó không lưu lịch sử ra
cái cuộ hội loại bình thường này nhá
nhiều lúc là tôi muốn lưu lịch sử ra nói
chuyện bình thường thường này để mà tôi
đôi khi tôi hỏi nó kiểu gần đây tôi thay
đổi như thế nào hay là nó sẽ đề xuất trả
lời trong những cái những cái cuộ hội
thoại khác ấy. Đấy
thì nó lưu ở trong kia nó không lưu vào
ngoài nên thành ra nó tôi cảm thấy là
chỉ nên cho một vài công việc phù hợp
thôi. Còn không ngày thì thường tôi vẫn
hỏi bên ngoài.
mấy cái nhóm cũng có bình dân học AI hay
gì đó, ông nào cũng khen AI, ông đấy xịn
ông ấy hạ à AI ông ấy đang dùng xịn thnh
ra là tôi nghe chán rồi không tin mấy
ông ấy nữa. Cho dù đương nhiên mình là
dân công nghệ mình vẫn nên thử nhá mình
vẫn nên không có cái đầu hẹp là tao chỉ
dùng cái quen thuộc thôi không. Thế c
nói là cứ thỉnh thoảng tôi vào dùng lại
thử cho biết thôi chứ bây giờ mình cũng
bỏ tiền con này rồi tự nhiên mình bỏ
tiền xong mình gọi như mình que khác
thằng khác dùng phải cực kỳ ngon hơn và
có những cái mình đang dùng tiện bên này
rồi thì mình mới cân nhắc đổi sang chưa
ạ đúng không ạ
mua chủ yếu code không game tầm bao
nhiêu ổn nhỉ 11 12 triệu là mua maxbook
cũ được rồi kìa Thậm chí là mua MacBook
Mini xong rồi bán phím chuột hay là màn
hình ở ngoài ngon lành luôn đấy. Rất
tiện.
Ma mini là rất xịn nhá. Nếu mà giả sử
bạn không thực sự là cần phải mang đi
nhiều. À nhưng mà bạn phải cân nhắc là
bạn đang là sinh viên hay không. Sinh
viên thì phải có laptop nên thế th còn
nhiều thứ. Còn nếu mà giả sử mà bạn cũng
kiểu đi làm các thứ rồi thì rõ ràng là ờ
chắc bạn hỏi như này chắc là cũng sinh
viên thôi. Thì mua MacBook E à cũng
được.
là tôi chưa từng dạy đại học vì chưa có
bằng thạc thạc sĩ để mà dạy
đại học. Tôi là giảng viên hổ trước là
cao nghề và làm giáo viên gần đây.
Em không dùng em dùng Google AI Studio
cũng không tệ anh ạ. Đúng rồi. Cái có
nhiều người cũng nhắc đến Google AI
Studio nhưng mà tôi bây giờ AI mọc quang
như nấm ấy
chưa dùng hết được.
hay vân vân giá rẻ hơn? đa số là người
ta sẽ người ta sẽ kiểu chuyển cái a điện
cái địa điểm gọi IP của mình đúng không
ạ? Sang bên nước ngoài sang những cái
đất nước nó rẻ và thêm nhì một vài thủ
thuật nữa để mà mua. Nhưng mà thường là
tôi không thích kiểu đấy vì nó sẽ có thể
dẫn đến rủi ro. Giả sử đây bây giờ thằng
này đang lưu rất nhiều thông tin của
tôi, tôi cảm thấy là nó cũng kiểu cứ cho
là gắn bó mình rồi. Tự nhiên bây giờ
người ta khóa tài khoản mình vì mình
thường hay kiểu lách luật như thế đấy.
Thực ra là tôi không muốn cho dù gần đây
là nó tăng giá cao thật. Rõ ràng khối
trước lúc đầu thời điểm lúc đầu mua là
48 này. Đấy sau về sau tự nhiên tăng đây
500. Ừ thì ra nó cũng tròn tròn đúng
không? Xôi về gần đây tự nhiên tính là
500 27 phẩy mấy kiểu lè lẻ lẻ ấy.
fix không mọi người nhỉ?
Cái này mình không biết. Cái này chắc là
bạn hỏi con AI khác xem nó có trả lời
cho bạn không.
Laptop cũ nhưng nó yếu rồi ạ. Ừ thực ra
là laptop nào rồi sẽ có vấn đề nếu mà
dùng Win. Mình vẫn khẳng định thế luôn
các bạn. Một là chỉ MacBook, hai là cài
cài Linux trên laptop hoặc là ba là dùng
hẳn máy cây.
nhưng mà rõ ràng là hồi trước nó số rất
là chẵn. Bây giờ nó số đúng kiểu để tính
theo tỉ giá luôn ý. Hai hồi trước là
480.000đ
tròn luôn. X 500.000đ. Nhìn tròn. Xong
bây giờ là 527
nghìn mấy trăm đồng ấy. Đấy rõ ràng nó
lẻ lẻ ra chứ chứ do ta ra chứ theo đồng
đô la thì mình cũng hiểu
live lại. Xin cảm ơn bạn. Từ đ dịch là
cách đây cũng lâu rồi hai 3 năm rồi. Uầy
mình cũng đây gọi là kênh có tuổi rồi
đấy.
lẻ lẻ lẻ như thế. Bây giờ gần đây cũng
tính thuế nhiều mà.
bạn ạ.
Nếu mà mua chỉ để cho
vui thì thôi.
Kiểu mình không cần nên lên điện thoại
chỉ cho vui đâu.
Cũng nhiều anh em từ lò dạy SQL với PP
của anh ra nhỉ.
Ừ không biết là về sau sẽ kiểu sẽ như
nào nhưng mà đúng là tôi đã từng gặp
những người à chắc chắn là gặp các anh
em thỉnh thoảng gặp anh em ngoài đời rồi
về đấy thỉnh thoảng tạo kèo mà nhớ nói
là có những lúc vô tình gặp ngoài đời
kiểu biết được anh em dê ha team này
thậm chí là biết được anh em biết được
kênh YouTube của mình này ui quá đỉnh
luôn cái lúc đấy mình có một tí cảm thấy
kiểu tự hào và cũng có tí kiểu không
phải như người nổi tiếng nhưng mà kiểu
như nào nhỉ cũng vui vui mà có người
biết đến mình và thậm chí là có người
bảo là xem video của mình rồi. Cho dù rõ
ràng là có thể họ không theo ngành đấy.
Đa số là không theo ngành mới biết kênh
tôi nhiều ấy.
anh?
Ờ hồi trước tôi thường hay gợi ý là code
my này đấy.
Ờ bình dân học ai này hiện tại tôi
thường hay theo dõi hai bên đấy. Còn IT
nào nữa nhở?
mấy cái fanpage nó đăng cũng chỉ đăng
kiểu
cho mình biết thêm tin tức thôi. Ấ, còn
kiến thức thì nó sẽ không còn nhiều nữa.
Chủ yếu là mình sẽ đọc từ blog
mấy cái trang tin tức thực sự ở bên nước
ngoài và mình đọc thêm sách kiểu mua
ebook hay các thứ thứ để đọc thêm chứ
không còn mấy cái kia là kiểu để giải
trí và kiểu cho mình thêm cái tinh thần
thôi chứ không không thêm quá nhiều kiến
thức đâu.
thể tiết lộ được này. Nhưng mà lớn tuổi
tôi ngoài già hay trẻ nhìn ông anh đấy
trông rất trẻ.
Không thể nói trẻ bằng tôi được nhưng mà
trông rất trẻ. Có vợ con gì chưa? Ờ lâu
lắm rồi tôi không nói chuyện anh đấy.
Chắc là chưa có con đâu. Vợ thì có thể
là sắp cưới rồi. Có thể. Cái này tôi
nghĩ là anh đấy sẽ cập nhật thông báo
cho trên kiểu công khai thôi. Có thể
không qu không công khai mặt nhưng mà
kiểu gì cũng sẽ công khai một cái thông
tin đấy.
Cái viplo medium ngày xưa nổi ác giờ AI
đâm ra kiến thức từ block bị người xem.
Thảo rồi. À by lâu lắm rồi tôi không vào
xem lại ạ. Bylo bởi vì có quá nhiều
người thường hay đăng lại chủ yếu là
dịch từ nguồn khác hoặc là đăng bị trùng
nên là tôi không còn quan tâm nữa. Còn à
còn medium thì đúng trên đấy vẫn còn rất
nhiều bài chất lượng nhá. Vẫn còn rất
nhiều bài chất lượng. đương nhiên là có
ai ra nhưng mà tôi thấy là nó không tác
động được nhiều lên đấy đâu. Bởi vì rõ
ràng là chắc là tôi theo dõi tôi có cái
tiện ích để mà nó luôn gợi ý cái gọi cái
tiện ích daily dep này này nó sẽ ơ đâu
không đăng nghiệp cổ đăng nghiệp lại này
đợi tôi một tí nhá
liên tục này cứ mở tab mới nó sẽ ra
những cái bài đăng như này để mình đọc
này mình thể downpod hoặc up để mình
kiểu tăng cái gọi là nó sẽ học chắc là
học một phần cái thói quen của mình để
gửi những cái hay này đấy một cách rồi
ông không cần phải lên một cái block nào
đó để xem đâu.
Không không,
ông vẫn nhầm đang Việt Thảo thôi.
Đã gọi là Anh Tuấn rồi mà.
cái nó không phải từng mỗi nguồn medium
nhá. Rất nhiều cái hay. Tất nhiên là vào
đây sẽ bị ngộp thông tin nên là tôi cũng
phải chọn lọc dần dần.
Google AI Studio. Đúng cloude thì nghe
nói là về code
mạnh gần như là mạnh nhất về trong AI
bây giờ tôi cũng chưa dùng bao giờ. Và
tính cả là tôi cũng
tôi dùng AI bây giờ là tôi hỏi thay kiểu
Google hàng ngày. Nó là một trợ lý kiểu
các thứ thứ ra mình khá là tốt trong
nhiều mạng không phải về mỗi mạng về
code nên thành ra là tôi không cần đến
thế.
Nói chung là code thì chủ yếu mình vẫn
tự code được mà.
xưng anh với người khác. Không phải vì
tuổi hay chức vụ mà vì tôi cảm thấy là
tôi kiểu tôn trọng kính trọng người ta
giống như là hồi trước tôi từng gọi Việt
Hảo cũng là anh đấy. Nhưng mà đúng là
anh Việt anh Tuấn thì là anh Tuấn lớn
tuổi hơn thật cho dù là có một lần tôi a
tôi không biết là hồi đấy tôi kể mấy ông
trưa mà có lần là kiểu à anh Bình là anh
anh sếp của tôi kiểu anh trưởng nhóm của
tôi nhé. Anh đấy có gọi điện anh Tuấn để
mà nói vụ gì. Xong rồi lúc mà anh đấy
nói với anh Tuấn xưng xưng em với anh
đấy có một tí
kiểu kiểu khựng lại ấy. Bởi vì nói chung
là tôi quen anh Tấm Tử lâu nên thành ra
là cảm thấy dần dần là kiểu anh đấy kiểu
cũng
như hai như kiểu thân như hai anh em
kiểu gần gần lứa nhau nhưng mà thực ra
anh Tuấn còn lớn hơn cả anh Bình đấy
nên thành ra tôi mới
hôm đấy thấy kiểu mà anh Bình anh đấy
còn lập gia đình rồi có có vợ con rồi
nên thành ra tôi vẫn
nhưng mà anh 1996 nhá nhưng mà kiểu Kiểu
nên thành ra kiểu lúc mà gọi anh Tuấn là
anh thôi cứ thấy sưng ấy. Đấy.
hay học thêm một ngôn ngữ khác kiểu
JavaScript? Tôi vẫn học JavaScript à tôi
vẫn làm song song full stack này có cả
JavaScript luôn. Ít ra là học PP mà chỉ
học mỗi PP học thôi thì không ổn. Mình
vẫn phải học
full stack. Hồi trước là tôi hướng đến
là không phải mỗi code mà tôi hướng
nhiều về database. Nhưng gần đây là tôi
đã biết được thêm về cái design button
xong rồi kiểu clean code hơn. Nói chung
là code mọi thứ nó đúng kiểu
để sao cho mà bây giờ tôi cảm thấy nó
giống cái quyển clean code và clean
coder ấy. Nói chung là tôi cảm thấy là
bây giờ tôi đã clean hơn. Nghĩa là người
code ấy, người lập trình viên ấy có tư
duy thì nó rõ ràng, nó logic, nó hợp lý
hơn để mà bây giờ mình đưa ra dòng những
dòng code chất lượng. Đấy chứ còn nếu mà
nếu mà hồi trước là chỉ đơn giản là mình
chỉ code được cho nó chạy thôi là không
được. Chờ mình phải có tư duy rõ ràng.
Và nói chung là bây giờ tôi bây giờ tôi
tự ạ hồi trước là tôi từng nghĩ hồi mà
tôi dạy cho mấy ông cứ cho 1 năm trước
hay thậm chí sớm hơn ấy tôi đã từng nghĩ
là hồi đấy mình có thể sino rồi vì mình
làm lâu rồi nhưng không bây giờ tôi mới
khẳng định là tôi mới thực sự là có vẻ
là sino hơn đấy
vì rõ ràng là
vì rõ ràng là kiểu bây giờ tôi mới đưa
thực sự là đưa ra những giải pháp
nên như thế nào suy nghĩ là sâu và rộng
rộng hơn. Hồi trước là đúng kiểu ngượn
non hầu đá là kiểu thấy có vấn đề cứ lao
vào giải quyết. Bây gi thực sự là ngồi
nghĩ xem là kiểu giải pháp nào ổn và nếu
có vấn đề gì phát sinh mình sẽ tìm được
hướng giải quyết nó chuẩn hơn chứ không
phải hồi trước là cố đấm ăn sôi vào một
cái xong rồi ngồi code trong lúc đầu ông
cứ hình dung ở bài toán lúc đầu chỉ có
một thôi đúng không? Đấy thì tôi code ra
cái 1 đúng không? về sau bài toán nó lên
thành hai thì tôi cố code vào cái 1.
Thành ra là cái 1 bây giờ lại trông rất
dối. Đấy thì ít ra bây giờ là tôi sẽ
biết cách
code sao cho mà nó chẳng động vào cái
một nó không ảnh hưởng cái một. Cái một
đôi khi nó vẫn đang chạy trong một vài
trường hợp thì hãy để bên nó chạy đúng
không ạ? mình sẽ cách sửa sao cho mà
không làm ảnh hưởng đến cái luồng hiện
tại. Đấy, đấy là một cái tư duy nó khác
biệt hơn rất nhiều rồi.
không cần đi sâu vào ngôn ngữ ngôn ngữ
nào cũng là nào giống nhau thôi. Ông
phải rèn được cái tư duy gọi là cho là
mindset à mindset dịch tư duy mà. Đấy
nói chung là kiểu để sao cho mà mình
giải quyết được vấn đề này vì tính ra
thì đấy bảo rồi bây giờ sino hơn con AI
ở mỗi thế thôi mà bây giờ thậm chí là
bây giờ tôi có thể nhớ AI code hội cho
rất nhiều cái nhưng mà rõ ràng là nó sẽ
không làm bài toán clean, không làm rõ
ràng được cái mặt nghiệp vụ mặt business
đúng không ạ? mình sẽ là người nắm chủ
được cái đấy. Thì bây giờ mà ông
chỉ mỗi biết code thôi để nó chạy được
ấy thì rõ ràng là ông đang bằng một con
AI và thậm chí kém hơn vì rõ ràng AI
code nó nhanh hơn và nhiều người còn
code trên code một kiểu dưới code một
kiểu thì làm sao bằng AI được. AI thì là
nó thống nhất trên thế nào dưới giống
hệt thế.
Anh chơi phím cơ custom không anh ơi?
Tôi không có bị nghiện cái ma túy nhựa
đấy. Ơ mấy cái từ đấy có bị không biết
bị chặn cấm trên này không nhỉ? Thế đại
khái là tôi không nghiện mấy cái sợ dụng
từ nghiện tiếp rồi nhá nhỉ. Tôi không mê
mấy cái món a đấy. Th tôi a
Nói chung có nhiều cái thì tôi
người bình thường được hay mê giống như
kiểu mê xe hay mê một cái gì đó. Tôi mê
một cái nó cự tôi cảm thấy là đã cố hạn
chế nhiều cái rồi. Hậm chí tôi từ nghĩ
tôi định đi tu mà nên là thành sẽ cố
kiểu kiểm soát được bản thân hạn chế mề
rất nhiều thứ
kiểu mình tịnh tâm ấy. Đúng rồi. Hôm
trước tôi mới biết được cái từ tịnh tâm
đúng không ạ?
Từ tịnh tâm thì nếu mà ông nghĩ kỹ thực
ra đấy từ Hàn Việt đúng không? Từ cả từ
tịnh và từ tâm. Tâm là tâm tâm hồn này
trái tim gì đó đúng không? Còn tịnh tức
là dịch ra là sạch. Đấy nó là sạch. Đấy
là có một cái tịnh tâm thì nhiều người
sẽ bị nhầm trong việc là
giữ cho mình kiểu bình tĩnh. Tôi h tôi
thường hay tôi nghĩ thế. Tôi nghĩ nhiều
người nghĩ thế chứ tịnh tâm là kiểu để
cho mình giữ bình tĩnh
không nghĩ không nghĩ đen tối hay không
nghĩ tiêu cực hay không nghĩ kiểu tà đạo
hay gì gì vân vân nhưng mà thực ra là
tịnh tâm là giữ cho cái
tâm hồn của mình sạch trong sáng
ở đấy tĩnh tâm chứ nhỉ tĩnh tâm hay tịnh
tâm nhỉ
tôi vừa nói cái ý nghĩa kia hình như là
tĩnh tâm ấy. Nhưng là đối với Tịnh Tâm
thì thì về tĩnh tâm nó đều na nả giống
nhau là kiểu giữ giữ bình tĩnh ấy.
Đấy đúng rồi. Ông kia lại bảo tịnh tâm
là tâm nặng như nước. Nhưng mà thực ra
tịnh từ Hán Việt nó dịch ra là sạch cơ.
Thế rõ ràng nếu mà bảo là trái tim sạch
thì rõ ràng nó sẽ mang thêm nhiều ý
nghĩa nữa. Ấ nghĩa là chỉ trái tim không
vần đục đúng không? Nghĩa là suy nghĩ nó
không bị kiểu ảnh hưởng. Nó cũng có thể
là tâm lặng như nước cũng có nhưng mà sẽ
kiểu hướng thiện hơn ấy. Đấy
anh biết anh nhân trong J2 không? J2
team Community thì đúng. J2 thì chỉ có
tám người thôi nhá. không có cả tôi hay
ông đấy đâu. Nhưng mà đúng ông đấy hồi
trước hình như tôi cũng gọi là anh một
lần rồi phải thì ông lại rất là giỏi.
Chính là em đấy em ấy rất là giỏi nhưng
mà nói chung là kiểu à ui bây giờ nhiều
người giỏi lắm nhiều người kiểu đáng
ngưỡng mộ lắm. Hồi trước là tôi cũng có
tí một phần ghen tỵ về với em đấy vì em
ấy kiểu giỏi quá kiểu làm được nhiều thứ
quá.
Bây giờ ông ấy còn lấy vợ sớm hơn mình
nữa, không giỏi hơn nữa.
Như ấy ra là hồi trước là ghen tỵ thì
khi mà mình để cái tâm của mình nó không
trong sáng nữa, mình có tí ghen tỵ, có
cảm xúc trong đấy nó bị ảnh hưởng, mình
không học được. Đấy, còn bây giờ khi mà
mình đã chuyển qua cái tâm mình trong
sáng hơn, mình đón nhận hơn thì đúng là
bây giờ mình mới biết cách lắng nghe
hơn.
Đúng nghe như tu mà tôi không hẳn tôi
tìm hiểu về tu đâu nhá. Nhưng mà tôi cảm
thấy là
nhiều cái ông không cần nhất thiết ông
phải lên chùa mới gọi là tu nhá.
Sợ là ông có thể tu
thiền hay vân vân. Tôi chưa thiền nhưng
mà ý tôi là thế là ngay tại da này để
cho mình bớt suy nghĩ độc hại thôi.
Giống như lúc đầu tôi có nói về khái
niệm clean coder đấy là người tập trình
viên vẫn phải suy nghĩ trong sáng. Đấy,
mình sẽ không bị mấy cái suy nghĩ tiêu
cực nó tác động với mình cả thử đúng
không ạ?
Hạn chế để làm ảnh hưởng
chứ. Bây giờ một khi mà mình có suy nghĩ
đố kỵ mình lại suy nghĩ giống như hồi
trước tôi tránh việc à để đồng độc tiền
làm thao hóa nó cũng là một trong những
cái đấy. Nghĩa là mình bị lòng tham này,
bị rất nhiều cái nó làm chi phối thì
mình sẽ suy nghĩ khó mà suy nghĩ
để giải quyết được một vấn đề gì đó. Vì
mình đang bận tâm nghĩ vào những cái
khác rồi đấy.
Em đang có nhu cầu mua laptop, anh cho
em xin mã lapt không? Cái này hỏi hơi
lâu rồi nhưng mà có một sự thật là không
nên mua con laptop của tôi đang dùng bởi
vì nó khá là đắt và tôi cảm thấy nó
không xứng đáng. Con ThingPad X1 nó chỉ
được một cái mỏng nhẹ thôi. Th ra là máy
nhanh nóng. Đặc biệt là ông Hà Nội này
cực kỳ nóng. Vừa rồi nóng xong đơ mấy
lần chán đấy. Cấu hình không hề khỏe gì
cả. Máy đến bây giờ đã có thời giai đoạn
kiểu chậm trễ trèo rồi đấy. Nên là
nếu có thể mua MacBook nếu mà làm lập
trình hay thiết kế một cái gì đó hoặc là
chuyển qua dùng chấp nhận bài toán việc
là laptop nó phải to cồng kềnh một tí để
cho cấu hình nó đỡ hơn. Đấy. Và ừ dùng
Linus. Nếu mà không thực sự cần Windows,
hãy dùng Linus.
thì chưa tôi từng nói là nếu mà giả sử
tôi không lấy vợ thì có thể tôi sẽ tu.
là gần đây sếp tôi nói chung là cũng
hướng dẫn anh em là ở công ty tôi là
phát MacBook rồi nhá. Nhưng mà vẫn còn
rất nhiều cái máy cây hồi trước. máy cây
hồi trước từng à
anh em nhưng mà c anh em dùng hết map
với nhưng mà map bây giờ cũng tốt bảo
rồi cũng cảm thấy là nó mình đang nhanh
hơn máy rồi nên thành ra là MacBook vẫn
nhiều lúc nó vẫn chạy chậm đấy thế nên
là anh thể cài hết Linus lên mấy con máy
cây kia xong rồi bây giờ mình sẽ kiểu
remote vào đấy đấy xong anh bảo là tốc
độ nhanh cực kỳ nhiều vì nó môi trường
nó vốn sinh ra là để code mà đấy thế nên
là đấy bây giờ anh em sẽ kiểu thế nghĩa
dùng MacBook mã remote vào máy cây máy
cây trên công ty giờ đúng như một cái VS
à VPS một con VPS riêng của mình đấy
đúng không à đâu từ riêng của mình nó
không còn đúng nữa vì bản thân cái từ
VBS nó nói từ riêng của mình rồi VBS là
virual server
Tôi dự định thì sẽ là 29 tuổi. Nếu mà
tôi không tính tuổi mụ thì sẽ sang năm.
Đây theo một bà bói nào đó từng chia sẻ
và tôi thấy là cũng hợp lý. Mình sẽ phấn
đấu như thế.
Ờ
nếu không gì thay đổi sẽ là cuối năm
sau. Tôi định là như thế.
Còn
mình đã chuẩn bị những cái gì cho điều
đấy chưa? Thì à tài chính thì ít nhất là
chắc là đủ tiền lấy vợ rồi. Tinh thần
thì
vẫn đang
vẫn đang cố ổn định.
Và những cái khác ví dụ là
kiến thức cũng phải cần kiến thức chứ
thì vẫn đang trao dổi
đúng rồi chạy 24 24 ờ chạy 24 24 liên
tục thầy có sao không? Thì
để mà nói thì rất nhiều máy sinh ra có
thể chạy được 24 24 máy cây được là đôi
khi cắm thấy vẫn được. Nó có nóng thì
được cái là mình có qua tản nhiệt mà. Ờ
đương nhiên là tôi cũng cân nhắc việc
làm thế hơi ngốn điện của công ty.
Anh ấy hơi lạm quyền và chắc anh em
không để ý hơi ngốn điện công ty cắm
chạy như thế đấy.
Nhưng mà về các bạn thì không cần chuột
hay bàn phím hay mọi thứ cắm vào nó.
họ từng nói có một bài đó là
web là xu thế của thế giới và đến bây
giờ web vẫn đang đều dùng. Các bạn vẫn
chắc là có thể đang dùng bằng điện thoại
nhưng mà thực tế là mình đang toàn bộ
bằng web này đấy. Thậm chí là phải
không cái việc mà bạn cắm máy cây một
tuần kia là Windows thì nó sẽ có thể thế
còn Linus nó không bị thế đâu. Đấy có
nói là nó bị nóng rồi. Nóng quá thì nó
thể thiếu ổn định thôi.
Thì thậm chí là bây giờ là có nhiều cái
app nó còn đang là web app kiểu web
nhúng vào app hay vân vân. Đấy thì ra là
web vẫn đang là một cái xu thế thôi. Vì
rõ ràng là bây giờ thay vì bạn phải viết
một cái phần mềm chạy được trên hệ hành
này rồi chạy trên hành kia vân vân. Thay
vì thế thì một cái web tương thích với
giao diện là đủ. Đấy rõ ràng nó lợi hơn
chưa?
Giờ anh có code thêm cái nào? Đấy thì
tôi bảo rồi code thêm JavaScript. Bây
giờ gần đây là tôi hướng mạnh về cả Fun
nữa.
Fun ở đây không tính CS đâu nhá. Không
giỏi CS lắm. Nhưng mà
nói chung là tôi không ngại làm full
stack hơn rồi và tư duy bây giờ cũng
thoáng hơn nên là xử lý đã có nhiều cái
t mà tôi từng nghĩ là phải tát dịch ra
gì những cái đầu việc mà tôi từng nghĩ
là tôi phải mất nhiều thời gian hơn
nhiều mà đã chỉ một vài ngày bây giờ đã
xong thế tôi tự tin bây giờ tôi xin vãi
chưởng đấy.
tết sinh việc thì ổn không?
Thứ nhất là về ra tết là một trong những
cái thời điểm có thể dễ sinh việc bởi vì
có nhiều ông nhảy ra nhiều ông vào. Thứ
hai là PP bây giờ tháng 7 à bây giờ tầm
đúng nửa năm nữa. Ờ
cá nhân mình thường hay nói là thực ra
cái này là nó cũng không thể chắc chắn
được cái gì nhưng mà rõ ràng là
thời gian thì không thì rõ ràng giả sử
học PP thật ra là nó không phải về m học
lập trình nó không thiên về mỗi ngôn
ngữ. bạn vẫn có thể làm
sang cái ngôn ngữ khác giống như là hồi
trước có nhiều bạn học PP của tôi nhưng
mà đi làm Java này có sao đâu. Đấy thì
rõ ràng là
bạn mà hỏi theo kiểu là có nên theo
ngành này không thì tôi khó trả lời. Còn
nếu mà giả sử bạn chắc chắn theo ngành
này thì học ngôn ngữ nào không quan
trọng. Bây giờ cứ học nửa năm là đi làm
được rồi. Thế thôi. Đấy ngại CS quá
không? Bây giờ thực ra cũng có những cái
có sẵn rồi. Mình chỉ viết class vào nó
ho đấy tôi toàn dùng chatt để mà à đúng
rồi chatvt ở trên MacBook hai cực trên
Windows nó sẽ không có cái tính năng
đấy. Trên Macbook kể cả cài app trên
Windows cũng không được nhá. Trên
MacBook nó sẽ có cái là mở mở thêm cái a
phần mềm bạn đang mở. Bao gồm đương
nhiên là phần mềm code bạn đang mở nó sẽ
đọc luôn cả file và chỉ sửa luôn trong
file của bạn cũng có theo coi như ngon
rồi. Đấy rõ ràng là
nó như một cái con agent AI để mà có thể
ngồi chat và chỉnh sửa được luôn trong
chính file code của mình. Đấy rất xịn.
mô tả
trang kênh của tôi sẽ là 96.
chắc phải thêm ra script nữa anh nhỉ.
Đúng nên nói chung là các bạn đừng có
nên giới hạn bản thân mình vì một cái
ngôn ngữ hay làm gì đó. Cảm thấy là bây
giờ
bạn muốn làm cái gì? Bạn muốn làm web
đúng không? web thì cần có giao diện
này, cần các thứ các thứ thì học theo
cái đấy thôi.
Nói chung là đừng có ngại kiểu phải học
thêm ngôn ngữ này hay gì gì đó. Một khi
bạn ngại là coi như là người khác không
ngại. Người khác không ngại là người ta
sẽ
gọi là thay việc của bạn được gồi.
Vậy thì dùng dish hop được. Đúng copilot
đúng rồi. Lâu lắm rồi không dùng luôn.
Nói chung là hồi trước là tôi cũng từng
mua meredu xong rồi ờ
cot về sau cũng khóa cái tài khoản đấy
thì phải. Hình như nói chung là mua mail
đu bên ngoài mà. Đấy thì nhưng mà lâu
lắm rồi tôi không được động có Pot vì rõ
ràng là có đây tôi dùng insert nó cũng
gợi ý một cách tương đối miễn phí rồi
cũng rất là thông minh. nó còn tự động
chỉnh sửa những cái khác nữa chứ không
phải nghĩa là ông sửa chỗ này nó sẽ tự
động gợi ý cập nhật chỗ khác nữa chứ cot
là nó chỉ auto complete hộ ông thôi nên
rõ ràng tôi thấy á cũng rất là ngon
không rõ là đọc được cả dự án không hình
như không đọc được các file ông đang mở
nên gợi ý nó cũng chuẩn đấy
à có pilot hồi trước tôi nhớ là hình như
không đọc được full xộc
Bây giờ không biết đã xịn hơn chưa. Nếu
bây giờ được thế thì cũng ngon. Nhưng mà
bây giờ cũng có nhiều thằng đọc được
full mà. Mà thực ra tôi không cần phải
full này đâu. Full này quá tải luôn. Bởi
vì tôi lắm file lắm.
Thì rõ ràng là tôi sửa đến file nào nó
đọc file đấy và tôi dùng chatity để mà
gợi ý thêm nhiều cái thì nó sẽ ổn hơn.
Ít nhất là thời điểm hiện tại tôi thấy
không có vấn đề gì trong việc code mọi
thứ hàng ngày vẫn nhanh vẫn đều.
nhỉ? Không hiểu.
thì ông ở cái copilot của Microsoft á.
Copilot của Microsoft từ chắc là tôi
không dùng. Còn GitHub Copilot,
Gitubilot là cái tiện ích cài ở trên
à. Winser. Ừ. Đây cái tôi đang dùng này.
Winsert này nó vừa mới bị mua lại
ới hôm trước thôi. Hôm đọc cũng hay
phết.
Nghĩa là đầu tiên này Open AI theo đuổi
cái bên Winser này lâu rồi. Winser thì
nó đang miễn phí khá là nhiều cái nhá.
Đấy xong rồi. À nghĩa nó mở mở đầu cho
cái cuộc giao dịch đấy. Ngĩa thương
lượng đúng không? Xong rồi Google nó vào
nó mua hai Google phải đúng rồi Google
mua hai cái ông CEO và ông Founder 2
phẩy 4 tỷ đô đấy còn đâu 250 nhân viên
còn lại với
Winser là thôi kiểu bỏ tao không cần đấy
sau rồi 250 nhân viên kia đang bơ vơ thì
tự nhiên cái thằng một ông bên
quên mất cách phát âm rồi nhưng mà đại
khái là ông đấy Cái thằng đấy thằng đứng
sau của thằng Davin AI. Cái thằng mà
thằng Davin AI nếu các bạn từng đọc thì
nó sẽ là
nó nó sẽ là kiểu
nó lúc đầu mục đích nó sinh ra là để
thay thế lập trình viên luôn ấy. AI thay
thế lập trình viên thể code từ đầu đến
cuối một cái. Ấ đấy thì thằng đấy nó mua
lại toàn bộ 250 ông kia kèm theo Winser
luôn. Nói chung là ông ông Open AI chẳng
lấy chẳng kiểu trắng tay chẳng được cái
gì trong cái cô giao dịch vừa rồi đấy.
Thế nên là Winsf bây giờ bị mua lại hoàn
toàn bởi thằng bên kia rồi. Không biết
là sắp tới sẽ có thay đổi gì không. Cho
dù ngay ngày hôm nay tôi vừa nhận được
mail là Winser vừa thêm một vài tính
năng. Đấy không biết là chuẩn bị sắp tới
có kiểu lại giới hạn các thứ các thứ
không.
Nhưng bây giờ là đấy có rất nhiều AI
cạnh tranh với nhau. Thành ra là ông nào
cũng có cái mức miễn phí nhất định để
cho mình tương đối. Ví dụ thằng Cuso gần
đây nó cũng tăng cái độ lượng à
tăng thêm tính năng pro nhưng mà nó
limit rate limit lại thôi. Đấy
thằng argument đấy. Hôm trước tôi dùng
đấy nhưng mà một cách tương đối thôi.
Tôi bảo rồi bây giờ AI nào cũng đến
ngưỡng midle thôi. Tôi nhờ nó làm đi làm
lại cái app nó đặt đi lại nó vẫn làm
không không hợp ý nên là vẫn chán vẫn
phải ngồi sửa.
có phải win search đ không? Win win là
gió đúng không? Đấy
là kiểu lướt sóng ấy.
Ngon này không do prom mình gửi vào nữa
đúng thợ thụ đắc lực của mình nó không
phải là sếp hay một cái thầy gì đó giỏi
mình trợ thủ mà đúng không? Thì rõ ràng
là mình vẫn là thằng
dùng từ copilot là một cái từ rất là
hay. Covot nếu mà ông dịch tiếng Anh ra
nếu tôi nhớ thì nó sẽ là ông phi công
kiểu lái cùng mình ấy. Kiểu thế
đúng kiểu trợ thử lái cùng ấy song hành
cùng rõ ràng là ông vẫn là thằng điều
khiển mà ông mà ông mà làm điều hướng là
sai thì nó sẽ vẫn sẽ sai thôi.
khản giọng rồi. Không biết mấy ông có
nghe giọng tôi khàn không? Nhưng tôi
khản giọng rồi.
Nhưng mà vẫn có người ngồi nghe giờ cảm
thấy.
một ngày dài và ngày mai, ừ ngày mai mai
sáng mai tôi 9:00 không phải 9:00 dậy
đâu. 9:00 là phải có ở quán cà phê rồi.
Mai tôi sẽ dậy tương đối không
muộn để ngủ nướng.
ngày gần nhất để ngồi livestream để mấy
ông ngồi chém gió các thứ sau. Đầu tiên
là mọi câu hỏi gì mấy ông cứ nhắn trong
kia tôi sẽ trả lời nhá. Hoặc nhắn tin
nhắn tin gì cũng được. Tôi chưa ngán ai
bao giờ đấy.
Thì để mà nghỉ ngơi này và kiểu nói
chung là hôm nay vào mục đích thực
livestream hôm nay là để mà thông báo
mấy ông tôi vẫn sống khỏe
so với đợt trước thì có vẻ tăng cân. sau
1 năm trước hình như tăng cân đấy.
À cũng có rất nhiều kế hoạch trong tương
lai và tôi đã có khá nhiều thay đổi tích
cực.
Tôi hy vọng là mấy ông cũng sẽ có rất
nhiều thay đổi tích cực đấy. Và ừ bây
giờ thời đại bây giờ có rất nhiều thay
đổi. Mấy ông thấy là thay đổi nhiều đúng
không ạ? Thay đổi rất rất nhiều. Mai cà
phê không có. Mai tôi có kèo cà phê sáng
mai đấy. Mấy anh em vào trong Discord
nhá. Tôi tạo kèo đấy. Đây. À
nói chung là mấy anh em muốn nói chuyện
thêm thì nếu mà ở Hà Nội thì thì cà phê
nói chuyện nó vẫn hay hơn chứ đúng
không? Đừng ngại. Đấy còn gì nhỉ?
Ờ đây đang nói rồi nghĩa là thời gian
vừa qua có rất nhiều biến động AI xong
rồi n khủng hoảng khủng hoảng kinh tế
khủng hoảng chính trị vân vân n thứ thì
không ai khẳng định là gì. đến cả chính
công ty tôi cũng có nhiều bất ổn thay
đổi các thứ có
thì hy vọng anh em vẫn thích nghi vẫn
sống tốt được có vấn đề gì thì chúng ta
vẫn sẽ có thể nói chuyện được với nhau
qua discord hoặc qua nền tảng nào đó
đấy.
tự bia tự diễn ấy. Nói nói liên tục hẳn
giọng.
Nếu mà để học cho có vui để cho kiến
thức thôi thì không. Học là để mà tôi hy
vọng là sau này có thể dạy ở đại học thì
có thể có đấy.
rất khó để lên lịch cố định bây giờ vì
rõ ràng tôi đang ưu tiên những cái khác
hơn nên thành ra là mới không thể kiểu
đăng cho các bạn một cái lịch gì đó cụ
thể là như nào đấy. Vì rõ ràng là đến cả
lịch học gần đây là tôi thỉnh thoảng tôi
có vấn đề phát sinh là tôi phải nghỉ cơ
đấy. Có chơi môn thể thao nào không? À
ở đấy là một trong những cái đúng không?
Tôi năm qua đến bây giờ là nó cũng chẳng
gì thay đổ mấy. Ơ hồi trước là thỉnh
thoảng có tạo kèo là anh em đi bộ rồi
xong cuối cùng gần đây lại hoãn rồi.
Nhưng mà ok mai sẽ
hôm nay nói mai quyết tâm đi bộ được mai
sẽ
được xếp mua một cái vợt pick b rồi anh
em cũng rủ nhau đi ấy và tôi không tôi
không hẳn là thích ở đấy lắm.
Đá bóng thì lại nhược điểm bởi vì hồi
trước bị anh em bắt nạt. Anh em trong
xóm bắt nạt. Chính xác toàn anh thôi chứ
không có em. Anh lớn tuổi bắt nạt đà
móng hồi đế khá ghét vào bóng đá.
Ờ chơi cầu lông nhẹ nhàng cũng được này.
Hoặc là tôi thích nhất là bơi. Đấy, bơi
với đạp xe mỗi tội đấy. Ừ. Từ năm ngoài
đến giờ ấ qua cái đợt FIFA đúng không
nhở? Ừ, cái đợt năm ngoái tôi bị trộm
mất xe cái thật đấy. Đấy.
à cũng có thể. Nói chung là anh em trên
công ty tôi đang có đi nên là hôm nào
tôi sẽ đi. Nói chung là tôi thì tôi nghĩ
là tôi sẽ cố mở mở đấy. Tôi bảo mở lòng
rất nhiều cái khử nhiều cái mới được mà.
Không sao.
Thôi thế nhỉ khả giọng rồi. Anh em nghỉ
đi ạ.
Chúc anh em năm mới vui vẻ. đã định
livestream từ đầu năm nay để chúc rồi
nhưng mà thôi năm mới vui vẻ nhá.
À tuy là đã qua nửa năm nhưng hy vọng là
anh em à trong đền năm qua
đã rất là xịn rồi và đến bây giờ từ giờ
đến cuối năm sẽ xịn hơn nữa nhá. Ok
xin chào các bạn.